welcome back to frenemies i jumped in on
that one
that's good this is your episode yeah
this is the episode produced
starring written by
trish today because this episode almost
didn't happen but it did happen thanks
to adam and eve and honey that's why we
are here
for round two we are here only because
of the sponsors
we wanted to take a break because
yesterday was really intense with the
jeff whittick
but we had to come back for our of what
you should say
i wanted to but you were cause i was
already gonna get glam anyways and i was
like i wanted to but i think you were
kind of like oh let's just take a day
off but i
wanted to i always want to do front of
me wait should we should we retake that
why
i don't know if that's funny no just for
the sponsor
that's not why we're here though can we
just keep going it's fine
it's obviously a joke we're here for two
hours you think we're here
does it seem like a joke to you guys
we're not restarting can we thank our
sponsors
yeah of course okay thank you adam even
honey that's not why we're here but we
wait no no no no no no no no no
no we're not restarting no it's my show
i'm producing it so i get to say the
cuts
okay all right i insisted on doing this
show today i insisted on so much i like
doing it i just thought like yesterday
was a bonus they shouldn't be punished
like we should have a regular schedule
like it shouldn't be punished it's like
when you're divorced and you get to see
your dad one extra day of the week like
you shouldn't be punished not seeing
them on the weekends as well like you
should see them on the regular schedule
that kid's close to home i'm just saying
i like it yeah you're right
you're right we gotta hit him with the
regular i think you're just
out of sorts because you're just out of
sorts today and i think that's why
you're not really honest well you came
here
flexing on me with your crazy ass joker
can i say i was supposed to be the joker
you said we're gonna dress as the joker
so i start ordering my outfit my wigs
everything in advance
and then you change it to pink and black
hair and i was like okay not so then i
ordered a pink and black wig and then
last night you're like we're not doing
that and i was like okay well i have the
joker wig already lined up why do you
pink and black again so i'm like i guess
i'll just go like this because you
you kind of just nixed the joker idea
you're just like not i was wondering
i'm like i had a long week yesterday was
intense i'm just i'm really over my hair
you said you were buzzing it which is
another
lie i was so prepared for you to be
buzzed dude
it's not like your whole day is rural
because i didn't buzz my hair and get
kind of
why because my outfit would have gone
with your outfit you could have been
robert de niro i could have been walking
so
i don't know what you said anything
about robin de niro i just said i was
gonna punch my hair yeah but that would
have looked like his in the movie the
joker like so it had a vibe
now it just looks like i'm an idiot
dressed as a joker no you look great and
i look like an idiot i had a sponsorship
which is why i'm dressed like this too
you'll see it on my tick tock so i had
to wear the outfit because it was
already planned
i dare you to [ __ ] say who's the
sponsor i dare you to say
i walked in and i was like oh well i had
to wear this for like a sponsorship and
you're like
you're bringing that into he has like
i'm not bringing it on i don't think you
were
of course i was you're just and then you
have a stain on your shirt which i've
never seen you have stains on your shirt
oh theo i was holding theodore and he
had an avocado traveled in so many ways
i said theodore please be careful with
that avocado daddy's got to work
but i'm just i'm just over my hair yeah
well it's not bad it's just not the vibe
that i want
in my life yeah i feel like you're just
not but yesterday was a long day and i
was like oh bro
you like i just because i didn't really
get a day off with sunday because we
work sunday and i usually have that day
to
recoup a little bit so you insisted on
the sunday show fyi because i was like
i'm kind of old
i'm glad we did it of course obviously
it was great no me too well
but here we are it was live it was live
how was your first live experience
it was awkward it was bad i mean here's
the thing like huh
like yeah you were totally great i know
it's just like i get so unique like
like if people feel it at home like
think about it here in person like it's
just 10 times more awkward like it's so
awkward because like
i don't know i've been in one lawsuit
before it was the same sort of thing
where it's like you know that person's
just so painfully in the wrong and
you're just have to like sit there and
like
hear the judge like i did a i had a
lawsuit again
i don't know oh i can say it's over now
and i want it i just haven't got the
money because you like
bankruptcy or something but it was about
my house like i rented a house once like
for
that i was living in anyways long story
short he basically owed me money and he
it was just like a clean cut case that
like he was so in the wrong but he was
so painfully trying to prove that he was
right and it was just like
the mediator was just like yeah and the
media is like you're
and you're just like oh just like stop
like that's what it felt like but at the
same time like
i don't know but i don't know yeah you
know
so by the way did i say our sponsors
adam and eve
all right thank you god bless good job
so i say this is trisha's episode
because i didn't have anything planned
so i put all my work into yesterday's
app so i said okay we'll do this
but trisha you're in charge so you're in
charge of this
but you have to go with it if i come up
nope i am going to sit here and you're
going to have to drag me along
oh yeah i'll do my best every time i
come up with the towel
nope next like you always have a next
for me
so that's why i was like okay i'm here
you take the lead
jesus take the wheel joker take the
wheel and i'm for the wreck i don't even
like joker
i don't like batman i don't like
anything good um thank you yes it was i
remember
joker with the peeking green bra yeah
totally
the green bra
yeah the only joker movie i saw was the
one walking phoenix that's the joker i
am today
i don't watch any of the other ones i
remember having rhinestones on his face
i did a little glam version of it
because i didn't want to go over the top
because you weren't dressing up so i was
like let me just be like a little more
low-key so i don't look like i'm gone
now i feel bad because what whatever
let's just move on
you can't tell me a theme and then just
like
abandon it because i plan these weeks in
advance you're right you're right
well i by the way right okay
you had told me like three different
times and first we're like harley
quinn's like oh maybe i'll be the joker
too like i was trying to think of like a
counterpart to you and now i just look
like a freaking
[ __ ] i think no you look great i look
like an [ __ ] i look like a
like i look unhinged bro if i saw me in
public i would like cross the street
yeah you look a little unhinged if i saw
me in a movie theater i'd probably leave
and get a refund yeah your your vibes
are low but you said you
you went to bed late so so anyway i do
want to say before we
pass the reigns to tricia i have i have
some kind of
post-mortem on this whole jeff woodick
interview post-mortem
yeah like it's like uh after the fact we
examine
we examine right so
jeff and his in
the interview we did admitted to a
not having read the entire article only
reading the parts about him which were
very little
b s apologize to trisha
for um trying to discredit her
and c also apologize to the author for
sending his fans to harass her
on twitter for an article he said he
didn't read now i'm giving i was giving
jeff a lot of the benefit of the doubt
yesterday
being like i know you're a good guy you
mean well i have a big problem with jeff
now one day later oh [ __ ] really the
fact that his video is still
up right his video is still up
despite him saying i have not read the
article
i i apologize for sending hate to the
author for an article i didn't read
like dude this this video is
misrepresenting
everything by your own admission and so
your fans who are watching this the
overwhelming like majority
right of people and views like um you
know a million
point three almost views are not are
getting
the wrong story from you and you know
that now
you have no excuse and so the fact that
he's left this
up to me is sign of a very bad faith
actor
and i am not okay with the fact that
he's keeping this up after everything he
said
in yesterday's episode and i think that
that is a very terrible thing for him to
do
yeah i guess i don't really understand
why he would keep it up because i feel
like
it's it's not the truth anymore yeah
my truth you know it's like it's like
you can't just keep this up to try to
save face with the people who don't
really know what happened do you think
he was disingenuous than yesterday
but he asked to be on the show he asked
me twice to come on which i was
surprised the first time i was kind of
like i don't know the second time you
know
he was a very again he's so different on
this than he was on the phone but i
don't know
like i feel on the phone i had a lot
more sympathy for him and this one i was
just like
dude i had sympathy for him yeah i have
sympathy for him on a human level i feel
awful for everything you're going
through you know
but why leaving this up is inexcusable
it's just not okay frankly i guess he's
still trying to get people on his side
you know i don't know
did he ever did he tweet anything or
anything after yesterday i didn't even
look
i don't think so i don't think he said
anything
i mean it was so brutal for him it was
like a literal murder on
i'm surprised it wasn't age restricted
because it was a literal [ __ ] murder
well it wasn't a literal
one maybe metaphorical murder right good
call it wasn't a literal murder you're
right
he hasn't i mean yeah you know that
photo by the way
which is surprising but not that
surprising because the reason i had that
photo
of him and david and todd all after
the victim was attacked is because it's
described
in the article as proof that
they were there all night right and so i
reached out to the author cat
and i asked her if she had that photo
because i knew i was going to talk to
jeff
and i wanted to have something that he
had to answer to right
and she sent it she said here it is and
you have permission from the
from the victims to share it yeah and i
was like
there was just so many lies and a shout
out should i shout out writer or no
shout out who read it they found
the video of me flashing them oh yeah oh
should i show that
i thought that was like and that kind of
pissed me off too because that
was so much because all i said was okay
jeff because he can't argue with that he
said that was absolutely not
planned and not consensual but like dude
it was in the video that like are you
guys ready let's show it because
i feel that when i saw that it actually
made me angry too because i didn't know
what the
so jeff said he's a come on like again
he was trying to discredit he goes come
on tricia
the first time i met you you showed me
your boobs like you like assaulted him
yeah yeah like no he's out you flashed
me so that's like implying that i'm a
pervert that just like randomly goes up
to people and like oh you're no better
than us
basically right and i was like first of
all i totally forgot about it so like
then
and then i was like oh and then i saw it
i was like but i knew when he said that
i was like there no that was a bit for
david that's why i was so confused what
he was saying
and the people that read it i know i've
always said like [ __ ] read it but
like we're back on team reddit now and i
thought that was so cool they could be
like my lawyers honestly they find all
this they're good
yeah well it shows todd and jeff and
like david literally is being like
setting it up and being like okay and
jason's right next to me so i don't know
he made it seem like i was this
whatever but oh here it is here it is
i found it this pissed me off when i saw
it because he
he totally that's reacting to church as
well
okay i was like you know what is he
talking about yeah i'm gonna put it here
and so here it is okay and like dude
sorry but i have to say [ __ ] you for
trying to characterize
it like that like dude this just just
bro
stop here it is definitely reacting to
nutritious boobs
i tried to say so
what the [ __ ] was that what are you
doing go to your [ __ ] finger yourself
in three two
oh one gosh where's your thing i mean
yeah this is [ __ ] insane
so it's like i it's obviously
pre-planned they're standing there
waiting for it they're like here we go
here's the bed
i mean you could have said bro like what
if you should be mad at any like yes he
looks uncomfortable if anyone you should
be mad at david
i mean but like i always do the whole
thing is not like i like because my
the whole bit was can i explain it in
full context like he has jonah
nick in the video show people his little
penis he flashes people
that's basically what it was is that my
they always made fun of my boobs because
they're scarred and whatever and it's
fine there's so much scars on them so it
was just like wow look how botched they
are like show them your boobs like it
wasn't like
hot like wow you guys want to see this
it was like embarrassing
he really is such a bully though like he
lit he
always hones in on like everybody's what
he perceives as everybody's like worst
characteristic
and makes that define them yeah for sure
look at jonah's got a little dick and
trisha's boobs
she's got a bad boob job and uh you know
even in the case of jeff
oh he's a criminal and right yeah and uh
tom's a sex offender
jeff was like we all play characters
like i think those are just stereotypes
that david gives us i don't know if we
play those but i mean i get what he's
saying you mean
i guess you play into it but like
there's no way and i would be like
hey todd and jeff like two good looking
guys i'm so insecure around good looking
people there's no way i'm gonna be like
want to see my like i wouldn't
this is why i usually date like older
guys and i mean most of my first
attractive guy i've dated but usually i
do ugly guys
and you know because i'm so shout out to
all your exes
they know people know i usually do
unattractive people because i'm very
insecure around
especially young frat guys so how is it
that you keep your
cool around me i'm kidding
it's so hard no but like wouldn't you
rather be like
have a good personality and a little
less attractive me
yeah yeah same like i know i'm not like
karina who's gorgeous but like you know
i think i have
like a better personality well i don't
know karina i do
i definitely have a better personality
but she's definitely hotter so i mean
you know
well i think it's you know beauty is in
the eye of the beholder i mean people
find you very attractive
okay but you're popping on only fans
yeah starting all over the mother loving
place
i don't i don't know why i put my only
fans and i never promote it because i'm
trying to be like low-key now because
i'm trying to do [ __ ] whatever
i've gained so many people on all events
i don't know because you're popping off
dude i know actually oh can i say i hit
5 million subscribers today
oh i've been out congratulations nine
zero
no four wow thank you that's awesome
i've been at 4.89 for
literally five years that's it dude
that's the [ __ ]
i never and i was like what is happening
like i don't i i never could tell i was
like am i just stagnant are people like
subscribe
like i don't know but i have 5 million
sayings i'm proud of you that that is
really interesting oh the tick tock i
hit 5 million before i even been on
youtube
yeah tick tock's crazy i hit a million
on tick tock with that like
oh congrats i love tick
this i did not like this but i mean the
kind of like game for him
but dude the way he characterized that
you're like it was a bit
and he's like i would never consent how
dare you
say that me jeff the me the man who
respects
all women consent to see my friend's
girlfriend's boobs i know
let's watch that again in 4k slow motion
hd
that's good dude i'm sorry about
that watching like listen this off the
top of reacting to nutritious boobs
i tried to say so
nobody's even smiling look at jason not
even a smile
the [ __ ] was that what are you doing go
to your [ __ ] finger yourself too
in three two one wow wow dude it's like
you could have like not
you could have like looked away yeah or
just not been a part of it you had like
a full
yeah like oh i just was like so
embarrassed and then i was like but then
when i saw this i was like wow thank you
somebody coming through because other
stuff i can like kind of hold my own
when you brought up like
i think people also have the wrong idea
about 5150 they think you're just
automatically a crazy person if you go
but that's also like if you just
even say you want to kill yourself you
get 50. so like they have the wrong idea
like what that means and that was six
months later i don't know the whole
thing it just made me i didn't sleep
well last night i was just like
yeah i was anxious yeah i was super
anxious last night too i think that's
why
i'm so uh disheveled yeah disheveled
thank you
yeah psychotic looking i think i was
super anxious last night i had trouble
relaxing and i just felt like
uh there was just a lot because like it
was so intense
and you would literally like as much as
like
i'm happy and proud of the work we did
in that episode
you it also feels bad on a human level
yeah like kill someone like that
metaphorically
yeah of course i mean i did everybody i
didn't kill jeff you know
well he said literal he said well also
everybody knows i didn't also literally
kill
jeff yeah so i have a lot of anxious
energy around it even though i'm happy
we did it obviously
no same i feel like overall just
everything with people coming forward
and like
feeling like okay to say something
against people makes me like happy
not happy but just like a lot of people
were speculating that he was trying to
like trigger you
because he kept like i don't know why he
thought it was appropriate first of all
to bring this
up total mischaracterization and then to
bring up like he's like
well dude you were you were you know
you're kind of or what it what's the
number 150. he's like you're 5150 like
okay dude what's your point
yeah six months after the effect i was
like okay like and i overdo it like it
was just so weird
like i didn't get it but the minute i
brought up like what's wrong with your
eye
don't talk about it don't you can bring
that up and i was just like oh my gosh
and honestly like people think i know
inside i just read i read like a vlog
the vlog or the blogs
is it a vlog blogs about the vlog spot
or whatever when that happened and like
um i just know there was some [ __ ] that
went down so i was just curious because
he brought it up like he brought up his
eye he brought up to me on the phone and
i was like well what
happened he's like [ __ ] talk about it
i was like okay i think what must have
happened is that he signed the nda or
something and got a settlement
it was definitely what david's well that
a largely which tablespoon because i
watched i read the vlog so something
with that
i have no idea what happened to it and
um i feel like i feel bad for that like
i still feel bad don't you think
like if it's true that he got
life-changing
injuries in a david vlog the fact that
they're even trying to keep it hush-hush
instead of
keeping it out in the open and having a
conversation about it to me
just shows how messed up david david's
like
philosophy and all this is like you
can't
give this guy life-changing injuries and
then just expect nobody to talk about it
it's just
it's happened before it's irresponsible
you've got it you have to let people
know
that the [ __ ] you're doing is
potentially dangerous and that you're
not going to put anyone in that position
again yeah and he never puts that like
disclaimer on the videos it happened
before though like jonah like was on a
motorbike across the pool and he didn't
have a helmet like i decided
like it's happened multiple times where
people yeah there's yeah and i was like
someone and i've always said it and it's
like everyone's like she's
wow she predicted this i'm like no it
doesn't take like a rocket scientist to
know like
someone's gonna get hurt like or die and
it's like really
it's it's it's sad and i just i don't
know
anyway well it's been quite a date
because there's been a lot of david
dobrik news about like dyspo
investors are all cutting ties you know
um all of his sponsors are
excuse me not all but a lot of them are
leaving and
he's just ignored things for so long and
like ignoring things is not the way to
go like i just like i don't know
i think this is the only thing that like
gets to him but i don't know
what do you think he's gonna do you
think he's gonna put out a video i i
personally think dave is just gonna
disappear
i think he's just gonna he's gonna peace
out for like
a year everyone's been very quiet
the whole squad because there's other
obviously there's other stuff about zayn
coming out about like groping girls and
videos so i feel like everyone's
quiet yeah i think people are just
trying to lay low so
nobody else gets because it's just stuff
that they should have addressed and i
honestly think
him losing sponsors could have been
avoided if he just like addresses early
on
rather than have it now everybody comes
up i think before
he could have survived but after that
article oh right well
i feel like that was there was no
escaping
the wrath of it's bad i mean that was
bad but there's
other incidents like that that i don't
know it's just bad it's all sad it's
like sad like again it gives me anxiety
too it makes me really anxious because
everyone thinks everyone comes for me
and you know like even jeff being like
oh gosh i started all this like it's my
fault and stuff and so then i get
anxiety and i'm like oh my god like i
don't want to ruin people's lives i just
you know bring like bringing light to
like a situation that i've been through
yeah but like it's not your fault they
never talked about it
yeah but like and then there was another
thing jeff said which he immediately
took back
okay but he go and this i think is just
another peek behind the curtain at what
the group think is back there he goes
well the girls did respond to an
instagram story
asking to have a fivesome and i was like
dude
you cannot seriously be saying that and
he's like i take it back i take it yeah
yeah yeah
like you [ __ ] better they all have
this really i think that's the worst
part about this group is that there's
really
zero remorse from them like nobody's
ever like sorry and it's like i think
confronting the truth is way too
terrible for them
and so they're they're circling it and
circling it and trying to avoid
actually confronting the fact that the
culture that they
that they you know lived for so long
enabled all these
victims yeah right and so
it's difficult to come to terms to that
so they're really just
rationalizing as much as they can but
eventually they're all going to [ __ ]
have to come to terms with it
yeah like answering an ad to have a
fivesome does not is not consent to
being assaulted sorry jeff that's crazy
i know
or even having sex you can you can
remove consent to have sex any time you
want i know
i don't feel like they get that because
it's happened multiple times i was
wondering what's david's sex habits like
does he
like because he's always having all the
other guy like is he sexual
no huh i mean he even said to me he's uh
like him i don't know what was it but he
had him in a like a girlfriend of his
like only had sex like twice the whole
time
what yeah that day and well she said
eliza was on whitney cummings and said
she's like never had an orgasm yeah
that was the crit that was the best
david exposed ever
um yeah i don't i actually have no idea
he's like sexual because like i just
find it odd that
he's obsessed with sex and but he's
doesn't have
any sex life perceivably he's like
by the way
to expose david dope before this you had
an orgasm no and i know you haven't
listened to the podcast
but i have not i have not at all and i
think how long did they die
damn no orgasms in two years well
yeah i think they only had sex like
twice so allegedly i don't get sue me
for that
what are they doing i don't know was it
a fake relationship
i i came towards the oh i think so
because well i don't know
i came like five months before their
breakup video and the whole time i was
there i
saw eliza like twice so i don't think
she i think either it was fake or i
don't know well
they're young too they were like 18 so
you know 18 year olds have like those
relationships i don't know
18 year olds [ __ ] as far as i know
that's true
yeah that's not a time not to be [ __ ]
he's like um
what's the opposite of like in south
like a a voluntary cell
you know what i mean like you know what
i mean okay
that's called what do they call that the
men going their own way what is that
mgdow
he's not a mcdowell no he's a mcdowell
no those guys are weirdos he's celibate
or just asexual
i think maybe that because like well he
talked about it on his podcast with
madison beer who is quite arguably the
most attractive woman in the whole world
like i don't think there's anyone more
beautiful than that girl
and she said how she wanted to date
david and like hook up with him and he
said no
riley reed is someone else who's also
said she tried to hug up with david and
he's like no like
so he got madison beer you got riley got
all these people and he like
says absolutely not i wonder what kind
of porn he watches
i wonder what he jerks off to you know
what i mean he talks about it if he
listens to his podcast i don't know i
can't remember i can't recall off the
top of my head but
i'm very curious about your sexual
desires
yeah it's because he's so devious it's
just i don't understand him as a person
i don't either and i was with him for a
year and a half like i don't he's so
he's so interesting i don't know there
was another clip that came up that i
thought was interesting of you and jason
trying to get away in hawaii
and he followed you guys hacked jason's
like uh
snapchat found the hotel room and
followed you guys like he would not
leave you guys alone it was very weird
it was like a week after we started
dating or no we weren't even dating yeah
it was like a weekend were you guys
pissed about that jason wasn't because
jason would be so miserable around me
and then when david would show up in
music videos he would turn it on
so he was like more excited once david
was there he's like yes we're gonna
we're gonna get in the vlog he kept
saying that he's like we're gonna get in
his vlogs
i'm like i don't like we i literally
didn't care about that at all like it
was so weird
i was so odd he was he's obsessed with
david they have such a weird
relationship i don't know
i don't know what it is well jason
wouldn't probably have a career at all
if it wasn't for
david so i get that but maybe david
looks at him like a daddy or something
daddy yeah he was weirdly jealous of our
relationship like david
so i know he never like liked it who
wait what
david was weirdly jealous of like our
relationship really oh he'd always like
try and like
break us up like with the cheating prank
and like all that other stuff like
do you did you ever speculate that david
might be gay
i asked him so many times in vlogs or
even not in vlogs even in real life but
he never he never told me i wouldn't out
him if he was but he never told me
no i don't think you have inside
information i was just no yeah but
um yeah i don't know i think he had a
really strong infatuation with jason
yeah he's very attached but maybe it's
like a dad thing like a daddy daddy
oh anyway whatever so that's that i'm i
i'm kind of losing any patience or
respect in summary
or any like benefit of the doubt you
know for jeff
because that video which is just a bad
faith video proven
bad faith bad faith shouldn't be up
yeah he said i apologize for
discrediting you well the whole video
and your call to harass the reporter is
still in your [ __ ] video bro
like stop i guess it wasn't yet i think
it i i guess it like
wasn't triggering because it just was so
irrelevant i feel like if it was i don't
know
i don't know nothing was i don't know
why maybe because you were here
you're my oh protector in this situation
seriously i feel like only people start
listening when you said something
you know which is fine which is you know
when we were on the show i saw people
saying that
too i i
i don't know i mean i don't know maybe
was it the first time that someone like
seth
and big nip were given like a relatively
large platform to say it so
maybe that was it because because big
nick reached out to you after we did our
david and jason episode
yeah and then seth so i thought yeah and
then this
article yeah the article was the because
we were just doing it as like an episode
because you didn't know anything about
it
yeah exactly it's crazy it's crazy how
it all came from but
did you see all the domino's memes how
it's like
this is the best meme ever people are i
think he's read it again i'm kind of i
need to get on reddit i keep
i don't want it i don't want to re no i
love red i've
i've i'm like i've been on reddit for
like my whole adult life
oh really um but i don't want to
describe it because it's so funny let me
just show it to you
okay okay here it is oh that was like a
pizza like a domino's pizza
i was like what does that mean the chain
reaction the domino's effect
oh my god oh it started it started with
instagram vs reality
down here and i went to jason's house hi
i'm matt you published that video it was
may 8th 20th
it was the night yeah it was on my
birthday may 8th oh [ __ ] that was a cool
2019. holy [ __ ]
yeah wow
did my video have anything to do with
like you yeah because i was getting
canceled by everybody i was like it was
just a lot
i'm sorry that was a bad timing for that
video i didn't realize it wasn't
and by the way in retrospect
yes i definitely missed characterized
you
as like you know i've said it before but
like you did the whole episode yesterday
without makeup yeah oh my god that
thumbnail just like my zit side of my
face was like all right
i mean but everyone's saying they stan
uh no makeup trisha
not me i i needed this episode for my
redemption to come back clamp makeup
i've been killing my looks every episode
well listen it's good
it's easy to look good next to me i come
disheveled for you
i came i didn't want to show you up i
wanted this beer redemption episode
i came with avocado stains my hair
this is all you well it's hard to look
good next to you though because your
shoulders are so narrow and feminine and
mine are so broad and masculine so i
look so
come on i look so big next to you how do
you want me to sit like this
yeah because you're such like little
shoulders thank you
i have such linebacker shoulders i hate
it i don't like the
handbag i look like i'm 200 pounds
heavier than you and all these sit downs
it's fine it's whatever
okay should we move on from david and
i'm sorry i do have i have a petite kind
of body yeah you do
you're the fat guy i was a petite man
who got fat
yeah you have a very adam sandler body
he's very much like that too was he
petite back in the day
yeah you're skinny and then
but he has the booty and the thighs too
he's got
the hips and thick as a snicker anyway
did you look at the meme
started with instagram reality and ended
with david dobrik losing sponsors
and fans stepping down from app his and
his uh that he co-founded get it
it sucks like the whole thing you get
the meme
because you said you have me you're like
meme challenged
i actually don't get this i like started
from the bottom now we're here
i don't get the domino you're like the
mom that like
i don't get i saw this comment it's so
funny she says trish is like the when
you show your mom a meme and they ask
who is that
or like you show someone they say who do
i know that person who is that
that is me i do say that it's a it's a
chain reaction
the tiny little force here okay what's
this video it wasn't tiny
oh it's set in motion all these
i can't explain means trisha you get it
or you don't
i guess i just don't really get started
from the bottom now we're here like this
is not a good place to be we kind of
it's not
that started from the bottom now here
it's a chain reaction it's a domino
effect
well they should have chains not
dominoes no it's a domino it's a chain
reaction
this is an ex okay this is an experiment
to show how what little force
can result in big changes so this tiny
little domino he pushes down and it
clicks that one
not a lot of force got it and it clicks
that one a little bit more but still
very little
it clicks that one you see yeah i wish i
had a domino's pizza
should we dinah did you eat this morning
i just had some oatmeal like nothing
serious i just had a bagel with peanut
butter and bananas and
quesadilla right but it's an appetizer
okay we had a great dinner last night
oh okay we're gonna throw it to break
uh be right back
honey honey honey honey
that's right that's who's sponsoring us
today it's honey
we all shop online and we've all seen
the promo code field that tons of said
checkout
with honey you don't need that it's just
a one and done well two one done
just download it to your computer and it
will scour the internet for those deals
for you the discounts will just come to
you naturally once you download it
free to download by the way it's free
and just two clicks bada boom you add it
to your extension
it's gonna sour the whole scour the
whole mother love and internet because
you know like let's face it dude
how many times have you bought [ __ ] and
be like damn if i only had a coupon to
be
slamming with epic discounts and how
many times have you bought stuff and
you're just like dang i wish i could
have some free money after buying this
while you did yeah
well that's what it is it's free money
hello i've used it at sephora i get that
coin from honey
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
you know what i mean imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
you get to the checkout honey drops down
a button and all you have to do is click
apply coupon
you wait a few seconds as honey searches
for codes and coupons that it can apply
to that site
and if honey finds a coupon you're just
going to watch that price
magically drop i bought a mattress and
honestly like for real
yeah if you get at jcpenney and get a
mattress those are like five thousand
dollars and you can get that cash
back dude there's some like um stores
like macy's jcpenney yeah where honey is
like
fifty percent you know whoa that dolce
gonna cure like smeg thing you guys got
us the tea kettle thing that was like so
bougie you could get that on like neiman
and then you could but you got free
money did you use it on honey maybe you
did i don't know i don't know eela
bought i don't know okay well
probably got like she probably saved
like a trillion dollars he probably
would probably
pay for it join honey.com she probably
went to joinhoney.com
you know honey has saved its 17 million
members
over two billion dollars that's enough
to pay for kylie jenner stylist brain
surgery
like what like i don't know millions of
times over right
but not enough for jeff bezos no jeff
no we can't buy him out with that jeff
bezos could save all of us money like a
hundred times
but maybe he's not rich because he used
honey honey jeff bezos
we don't know he uses him he didn't
notice it no he does not endorse it we
don't know
well anyway if you don't already have
honey you could be missing out on free
money
and free savings it's literally free to
install and only takes a few seconds
and by getting it you're going to be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast thank you thank you we love
it
i'd never recommend something i don't
use they made me say that which feels a
little corny but i do use it i've used
it yeah i don't like it
because once it's in your computer
seriously like once you don't have to
like keep downloading it just on there
like it's like yeah and also like the
process of installing it is so easy you
literally just go join honey dot com
slash frenemies click it and then you
add extension
boom easy sorry i'm just getting hyped
up overall my microphone got excited too
anyway uh get get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
okay that's join honey.com frenemies
nice today's episode of frenemies is
sponsored by
adam's plugs oh nipple claps
nipple planks i didn't bring them but
nipple play is all the rage these days
yeah it really is they haven't they have
like weighted ones like with balls on it
it's so amazing
oh mine are fake my nips are fake and
honestly i still feel it through these
things like
your nips are totally fake yeah because
i got them downsizing these two how
would they make them out of
um they just cut them down they just
come down when i had my boob job but
anyways wait but so it's a real nipple
right it's just like that a little it's
been a little bit it's been a little bit
snipped but it was desensitized for so
long and these nipple clamps have made
me feel things so go to adamne.com
and use the code h3 for 50
off any single item plus free shipping
if you're in the us in canada but also
this h3 code
gives you free movies free spicy gifts
for him her and together and for him her
and the dog and they if you're they the
author not the dog that's disgusting i'd
just be like him
who and who else are they like if they
don't identify as a gender they have
those for you as well
sorry about this if you're asexual i
don't know if they can help you well
anyways
go to adamandeve.com and use the code
history it supports the show you can get
nipple clams for 50
off because some of those can be pretty
high they also have the thrusting
inflatable heated toys that i'm
flustered inflatable tube man sex toys
what say what
it's inflates inside of you it's really
cool you told me about that yeah the
heat once again
did you push a button or how do you tell
it
okay it's a button okay actually yeah
can you inflate it too much or is it
like no it fits perfectly
to fill your desired holes i would have
met oh some women's vaginas are probably
more cavities it just knows it goes with
what oh it stops automatically it just
knows it really does just know
you can't say that about anything human
smart uh smarter than a human it's a
smart
vagina filling they know how to build
you so if you want to get nipple plants
g-spots there's
you know all thematic stuff there's
thematic butt plugs for saint patrick's
day i got a little luck of irish
you got it you gotta theme your
buttplugs folks definitely get it
they've been around 50 years
adamandi.com has been around for
50 years they're based here in the
united states the package is discreet
when it comes to your house does it i
always imagine don't nipple clamps hurt
or zap the paper that's the
that's the point you want a little
pleasure but it feels good but it also
hurts
don't you like when people bite down no
i don't okay well not for you but
there's other things for you there's
like
anal beads there's a clone of willy
you can clone uh i'll clone my dick yeah
you can do that next thing i need
you can get the throat spray your throat
i'm trying to forget what my penis looks
like not
to make a mold you give that to a gift
for elie like look i cloned this for you
now you can have it by yourself
great she's like great just sell it you
could auction it off for a good cause
more than awesome well we'll just keep
going anyways
dot com code fifty percent off of using
code h3 plus free shipping if you're in
the us and canada please support with
the quotation three so you can
explore this please get yourself a 50
percent off goodie
it means to try out deals you want to
give me the name yeah i'll get you the
clamshell with our code 50 off i'll try
it okay maybe the next segment
our next episode you can climp it on me
yeah do you have little ones or big ones
tiny perfect that's even better clinging
all right lips are hurting just thinking
about it i'm gonna go on you'll try all
right adam and eve dot com slash
h3 is that right no the code h3 at
checkout code h3
adamandeve.comcodeh3 come on
adamandeve.com code h3 support the show
support your
favorite frenemies and uh that's about
wraps that up in it
what's that that was my that was my is
that your sex face what was that
i'm not cutting it misses don't cut
anything and all of a sudden don't cut
me going
all right thank you guys h3 anime.com
i asked you what we had for dinner but
we ate together which is just fruit
for dinner so out of it we had orange
chicken that you paid for
yeah how much was that i don't know 100
bucks
yeah something like that what
i mean it was for a lot of people i love
like i love being here but i always feel
like
so awkward being here after hours i
don't know i always feel so
you were pow-wowing with the with
moses's mom that was nice oh my god i
okay i've been sticking my foot in my
mouth so many times
in so many situations no well last night
but also like i mean with zach when i
saw him last week during the cooking
thing
and i was like so nice to meet you in
person he's like we've met like so many
times before and i was like
and then i was like no we haven't then
he said i get so i'm serious the most
awkward person and i
literally i just asked you what you had
for dinner and we ate together yesterday
so
right well you're awkward too that's
what i'm saying but no yesterday i was
trying to impress like moses mom with my
hebrew a little bit
and i was like you know and then i was
getting comfortable so i was like oh
moses describes this word like benzo not
as like wow it's [ __ ] good oh why'd
you say that
benzo now it's like a really vulgar
curse word but no he's like sometimes
you could say like oh this food is benzo
now like it's so freaking good
but moses has to be in the car that
means your mother is a [ __ ]
yeah mean son of a son of a [ __ ] you
tell me it's like wow
congrats like good job ben zona so
that's what i was saying and i was like
that's bad
food tutoring
she probably just laughed was she taking
a bag
you know her yikes
i don't think i think she knows that you
don't know ah
that was awesome why are you telling her
to say
you said that's like oh that's freaking
good this is a son of a bird
[Music]
so you came over yesterday and called
your future mother-in-law [ __ ]
oh my it was so bad uh when he said that
in the car because he said it right away
my students were getting because you you
know ben's
like oh my god oh moses is thinking
about this and if moses is thinking
about something that means it was bad
you guys didn't address it when it
happened no they all laughed elo was
there too okay you guys a lot okay good
i'm glad you guys at least addressed it
i didn't know i honestly was like this
is so good but it's good you're trying i
think when you're learning a
a language do you you have the best
attitude about learning language
is that you have to not be shy and just
speak it without filter
and that's what you did that was
genuinely i was like never speaking
hebrew again
and then the exact thing and it's just
it was good though but no his mom is
actually like
you guys are hitting it off yeah she's
way more outgoing and social than
like moses and eli like you know at
first it can be like a little hard to
you know to warm up to you
not that they're cold or anything but
you know what i mean like oh i'll speak
for moses not ela like moses is like
super awkward you know when you first
meet him he's kind of like
in my opinion i was just like oh he's
kind of cold he has his feet his guard
is up like
neil is the same yeah but yeah it's
interesting because their dad
well i don't know your dad was pretty
social that was weird
well he she has the same energy she was
nervous to me too too but you guys hit
it off you just did really good
outgoing is what i'm saying i feel like
even with moses it was so hard to have
conversations at first
i think you're integrating with the
family really well thanks i have i'm
having a great time and i love and this
is like the third time now
you guys are doing great yeah you guys
are doing great happy for you guys oh
you got a mic
well then just handed me oh okay we've
had lots of requests for
moses to be miked so thank you dan
well now speaking of that it's a great
segue to
my portion of the show go ahead this is
all you know i'm pat
i'm taking a back seat go ahead trisha
hug
pesach some air it is passover this week
hog sameach hug somewhere wait
it's passover this week yeah so in honor
of passover i came out with a passover
song
called i love you moses to sell the
story of moses and passover and why we
celebrate passover
i wrote this song with all the intent of
telling the passover story to people
and um it's out today it's called how
many views are we at
you're at let's see we're at 2 50.
that's amazing for me i usually get 100
000 views on my videos here let me like
let me like and then let's watch it
everyone go watch i love moses
after the show the whole thing you can
you know well let's see how entertained
i am
oh geez it's a great
i mean because you have i mean it's
pretty epic you've got moses playing
moses
who's also your fiancee so you love
moses and you love moses and this is a
cover of a really classic song called i
love you jesus so
to the tune of i love you jesus yeah so
it's a it's a sequel
so you're so it's kind of interesting
yeah so
so you've you've jumped shipped you no
longer
do you still love jesus yeah jesus
brought me moses so i love them both
do you love them both equally for sure
you love jesus just as much as moses the
the prophet no i don't know him i just
love moses hochman
okay you love moses as much as jesus
yeah this was just more of me being
creative and trying to
appeal more to my fellow jews and but
you have no affinity for moses the
biblical prophet
i think i do you love him as well um but
less than jesus
for sure okay i mean he he wasn't the
son of god
he's just a voice of god right mm-hmm
fair enough yeah
[Music]
how much you spend on this 80 000. i'm
surprised you could put all this on
foreign and the amazing color dream coat
because it looks like uh it looks like a
like native american uh when they do
peyote and do the bead art
no it's old testament is that old
testament joseph yeah
but they were all like tripped out and
like yeah psychedelic oh he was given to
it and his brothers were jealous so they
stoned him and sold him to
egypt oh for real yeah that's keep lore
deep biblical alar
you should know i'd be jail i'd stone
your ass for that outfit give me that
[ __ ]
where is it that's fly as hell donnie
osmond played joseph in the movie that's
why i
love the movie so much live thank you
without a throne how could i've known i
love that
how could i have known okay remember
when i was alone
just a queen without a throne how could
i've known
how could i have known epic do you wanna
do a song together
yeah i'm tall i told you i'm down would
you did you tell me that i feel like you
didn't
i think you you haven't asked casually
before but i am down yeah
i feel like it'd be really cool it'd be
something
i love music videos would you record too
would you record
i'm all in okay whatever you want i'll
do it i always get so nervous to ask
people because i feel like
i'm down i cringe at myself sometimes
but i feel like
but like i mean i'm not expecting to
take myself too
seriously no no no it's not gonna know
what i mean but i don't want to like
embarrass you you know come in
videos okay okay okay i'll do whatever
you want me to do yeah so i'll pitch it
to you
in a minute later bye picture now no
come on i want to hear you no i have to
get you the demo and i gotta get you
like demo just tell me the idea
it's not that serious no okay it has to
do with our black and pink though and
kind of like um it's kind of like think
blue man group but
blue man group are you serious okay i'm
in
oh god you were it is embarrassing
you're right
i'm gonna be in like all black
taking balls out of my mouth and [ __ ] no
but like splatter paint and stuff you
know like that kind of stuff
okay we'll talk about it i'm in whatever
you want i'm in
oh man i'm gonna also be funny and like
the blue man outfit because i'm fat
because you know they're in like tight
body suits well no because you're pretty
fit now
you're pretty like with the black cause
you know what i look at
video of you from like when we started
and i think you're way skinnier now to
be honest
maybe for sure yeah that's when you
don't weigh yourself and when you don't
care is when you like just naturally
like look better
we're not we're not gonna be very far my
mind was gonna be
blown it was blown it was blown
you like that too i didn't do that on
our song we can do
[Music]
can i ask you yeah so are you playing a
biblical character or
no i'm the narrator you're just the
narrator who's in love with moses the
prophet
it's a devil and tanja right right right
because because then i say in this next
part moses [ __ ] did moses the prophet
[ __ ]
yeah he had a wife and kids oh he did oh
of course so that was
so nice her name was zappora my dad
always calls me that
because my dad's very like into religion
like he's catholic but he knows like
about old testament and he'll always
call me like zapora
because i guess that's the wife of moses
we both didn't know that we're like oh
weird
yeah he'd always text me he's like oh we
shall call you support i was like who's
that
weird he foresaw the future your dad is
prophet
[Music]
i think moses was a good lover the
prophet
he had moves he had like [ __ ] like
biblical moves spreading the sea
and turning the snake my theory on that
moses is he probably was
high on like ecstasy or acid when he saw
the bush burning
and you can't get hard on those kind of
drugs like your penis literally goes
back inside when you're on like
hallucinogens so not a good lover you
think he was tripping balls all the time
he's part of the scene burning bush like
what was he on you know he left being a
pharaoh to what
to like like a broke ass eating like
like matzah in the desert like sorry
nobody
[Music]
so what did you mean when you said smear
the blood so i said the bush was burning
bright not an israeli in sight
smear the blood pass over us so when so
i'm explaining the passover yes smear
the blood
pass over us moses the voice of god okay
i was just asking because last time we
had our jewish trivia you didn't you got
that question wrong
the smearing the blood because wasn't
that a plague
oh because i thought he said come man i
thought he was talking about this
i'm just vibe checking you i know that i
wrote whole song about moses and the
passover
all right
[Music]
you guys gonna [ __ ] around some sheep
[ __ ]
what's with the sheep that's just part
of the size
[Music]
when you guys were watching upstairs
that you can see it being popular in
israel
that was moses i said that you see this
being
[Music]
i know they're not like i know myself
they're not good so he's like this is a
bop this is gonna
and he swears they're gonna be a hit
he's like no this will be so big well
everyone in israel starts streaming this
let's get it trending in israel for the
holidays
oh yeah just in time for passover i'm
loving it
yeti
you should put subtitles like oh we ran
out of time we just shot this last
wednesday
you can add it can you add it in the oh
and the thing
why not you you i can't edit no you can
yeah well learn hebrew you don't need
subtitles just figure it out
right
[Music]
like the holocaust numbers were greatly
exaggerated because nobody can
understand no
i'm literally not i'm time again once
again talking about exodus
and that was only beginning work hard in
the words of moses
on passover
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
who are these guys you got out there
those are characters from my favorite
israeli movie
zohan and phantom why is he wearing a
mariah carey shirt because adam sandler
wears it in don't mess with the zohan
he's a mariah carey fan
he was supposed to have a goatee and he
doesn't look as much like adam sandler
as i thought but that guy looked like
freaking john tuttoro the guy who plays
phantom take away
so are these just extras you got
[Music]
craigslist
at this lady look at this whole thing
was this guy really orthodox or was he
just playing one for tv
he was israeli he was he was speaking
hebrew yeah but what's he is he
orthodox he's an actor he's an actor
wait but he's probably orthodoxy he's
from israel girl he's from israel
my wife is from israel and that lady was
uh latina why was strazian
hmm a bunch of non-jews uh
yeah sacrilege it was greek persian
latina
israeli so there was one on the end with
moses so i love it though
okay we all celebrate together
[Music]
version of the old testament where
there's someone dancing around
the burning bush and like halter top
what do you call that tuba
i love you more
oh [ __ ] this this chapter is banging he
probably
loves it actually his chapter's off the
rails
he looks like moses they're like yo why
isn't this in the old testament
yeah moses precious as jesus yeah this
is his first time playing moses
[Music]
it's so funny that like moses is the
perfect
i know your little story he's getting
older so
you play moses now i love the goats
there was a shot of the goat real fast
wait let me go back they cut in the goat
real fast they're like all the family
the love
the romance goat
[Music]
yeah that was it it's a banger dude
straight
the [ __ ] up wow get this charting in
israel people
we need this charting for sure moses
thinks i could go on any show and israel
is a celebrity because i love like this
big brother over there like do you think
they let me out he's like oh for sure
you'd be a celebrity
yeah the celebrities are not that big
there right
well as an american celebrity she's big
over there exactly
shout out to iliad my favorite israel do
you think i could get on big brother
there
yeah for sure oh he thinks you are dead
maybe we should invade
the israeli invasion for our wedding
i haven't been to israel so long i can't
wait to go
should we do a friend of mine's over
there yeah you floated that idea i kind
of like it i like it too
we'll probably go there well yeah we'll
probably go there when you get married
there
yeah we could do a friend of miso
um speaking of ideas for future shows
this is i'm going to put you another
idea
keep youtube oh what is that oh that's
that guy
name um okay i have another idea for one
of our frenemies
and then i have more topics to talk
about but like let me push this idea
while we're talking about ideas
have you ever do you remember the show
legends of the hidden temple yes
what you do yeah of course nope the
aggro no no not the aggro crack
come on was it that's no the aggro crack
was guts
oh yeah legend of the hidden temple was
the one where it was in like an aztec
temple no i remember that too
what was the final didn't they have a
final [ __ ] pyramid no you're
confusing it with guts
how did aggro how did the dagger crack
was guts okay i get it
what was the damn it was just the hidden
template i remember the hidden tell you
it was simple and then people would come
out and grab them
yeah and get up with the monkey together
at the end but they were like okay can
we recreate that can we
do our own at legends of the hidden
temple or we're the compe you want to
make a show or you just want us to have
a legends of the hidden temple
oh i don't know maybe first i want to
like try it out and do it like i want to
be a team with you you remember they had
like the barracudas and they were like
silver shirts together
so you want us to compete yeah i don't
know how that works but maybe
so we have to make the show i want to
make the set and everything
hmm so you want to make a game show
yeah but just for us to compete on it i
don't know i didn't really think it
through i just really want to do it i
had so many ideas and that was one of
the ones i wanted to do
i do think that there's potential for us
to create a show together
i guess we could bring it back i guess
it's for kids but i want to play it too
well there's some adult ones too like
the american it's kind of like american
gladiator
you know type of show i feel like if
discovery gave david dobrik a dodgeball
show they'd give us a legend
yeah you didn't know that he hosted like
a dodgeball show and just even
care about dodgeball that's just so
stupid like bro you don't care about
dodgeball
stop i don't know just inflicting pain
on people without their consent i guess
part of the dodgeball game dodgeball is
so messed up
i was scared to dodge when i was a kid i
was like i this game is
is barbarous i do not consent and they
force you to play too
yeah and like i'm like a relatively
small skin i'm not athletic like i've
got small hands as you would
love to point out so i
no i don't care did you think about it
before i said it though you knew you
thought i brought before i said it
you said something insulting to me so i
said something something to you it's
fine but the problem is like i played
water polo in high school
and i feel like i was pretty athletic
but i could never be good because my
hands were
so small i couldn't grip the ball so it
was a big problem like i had to like
hold it like this
so that's so i feel like i was
handicapped in that regard
and so dodgeball i had kind of the same
problem and so i was just
i just you know and there's like these
big try hard kids that really just want
to [ __ ] you up
yeah they were so aggressive like like
boys would hit me and i'm like okay
that's like
what the hell i can't even compete i was
like just a roly-poly
see we were different in high school or
in middle school i was like tunky you
were skinny
you would have blacked out a lot of
impact though
what you could probably absorb a lot of
impact
of the bar yeah like a yeah
i don't think that's how it works no
that's just a really big target i don't
know you probably would have made fun of
me i would make fun of you for sure in
middle school i wasn't i wouldn't make
fun of you
you would make fun of me yeah i believe
that i wish i had i wish i had the
ability to in middle school to make fun
of you do you want to go back in time
and bully me
i never got to bully anybody i guess
that's a good thing right i don't know
probably is a good thing i couldn't do
it i feel so bad but
yeah but i agree bull uh dodgeball is it
should be outlawed
okay it's violent you shouldn't for
you should not force people especially
to like it's fun for some people but
some people are terrified to get in the
ring the you know the vipers pit and you
shouldn't force them to get in there
i want to do legends of the hidden
temple okay discard
if you're watching discovery um
okay next topic i feel like it's kind of
like not a hot topic anymore but i just
think it's i have something to debate
not a debate but yeah debate
with my my glam squad today the people
who do my hair makeup they're my friends
too ari and angel and i like love them
so much
and anyways we were talking about this
guy in the glam world his name is makeup
by samuel
and he was in a really bad i guess it
was a go-kart accident in miami like a
week and a half ago he was with nikita
dragon la demi
he got ejected from the go-kart go-kart
yeah they were in a go-kart yeah that
was the details of the story did you
have such a tragic go-kart accident what
happened
you could go pretty fast yeah they
didn't have a seatbelt on
he was like allegedly what i heard is he
was like twerking out of it
okay so but
it was it's really sad because he you
know he's pretty much gonna be brain
damage for the rest of his life from a
go-kart injury well he
he got ejected from the car his head
like crashed into the pavement
again this is all legend i don't know
but like from what i heard his boyfriend
didn't want him to go to the hospital so
he said he'll be fine to sleep it off
oh they didn't i know they didn't take
him to the hospital so the following day
to which he had severe
blood like hemorrhagic probably would
have been fine if they took him
immediately
well yeah so then he needed this brain
surgery and it was
60 000 and so kylie jenner who have
i i guess uses him yeah she uses him as
her makeup
artist from time to time it's not her
main makeup artist but she uses him he's
also the best friend of her makeup
artist but anyways her friends use him
whatever she knows him
knows him enough to repost the gofundme
because he did a gofundme for 60 000
and she reposted on her page you go to
the gofundme and kylie jenner donated
five thousand dollars so like the debate
was was like
should she have paid for the whole thing
or that's what i
said and everyone's like it's so
embarrassing that
she instead of just paying as a
billionaire i feel like if one of these
guys got brain i'm
far from about like a far i'm not i'm
not
i'm closer to being i'm much closer to
being broke than being a billionaire
right right yeah
if one of these guys got brain damaged
or something i would definitely pay for
their surgery that's what i said too i
wouldn't even i'm like lower than you
i'm like i'm barely you know i have to
like
scrape up for birkens but i would
totally do it too late
let's not pretend like we're broke i
should go from
something for birkens but yeah no it's
it's pathetic it's pathetic that she
thought share
asking her people on twitter or
she's like well my huge people usually
have to pay me a hundred thousand
dollars for a
instagram post so i'm doing it for free
it's like shut the [ __ ] up you're a
billionaire
shame on you right i feel like disgust
yeah
i think in that case like you also
discussed okay i thought so too but then
uh people did like we're saying like oh
you know even my sister's like well if
you're rich you shouldn't just have to
have to pay for people yeah but
it's like well like but you're asking
other people that's what i said
just use your [ __ ] head you're a
billionaire just
like yeah stop or just don't post it
like if you're gonna be that
like cheap don't post it like you know i
guess i see i guess i see the point is
she's like i'm willing to give five
thousand dollars
so it's like should she post it to get
more money in there or should she not
but at that point she really got to ask
herself i should just
i should just donate the whole amount
yeah because i was thinking in like
terms like sixty thousand to her is
probably like six thousand dollars to us
you know what i mean which is
ray really yeah so like six hundred
dollars a billion dollars is a thousand
million dollars
it's probably like you know uh 50 cents
or something wow you could crush the
numbers on that but it's nothing
okay so in that case that's what i said
too because i i would donate to 2 000
and i don't have it
yeah she's filthy rich filthy rich how's
these i just yeah
that was the big thing it was crazy i
mean now everyone's doing gofundme so
another makeup artist got his kit stolen
so he has a gofundme for that i mean
it's more of a statement
oh his kit stolen yeah someone stole his
makeup kit out of his car
and he just did j.lo's makeup for the
inaugurations that were kind of like huh
um it was worth fifteen thousand dollars
he said
and he people donated and raised the
money but then he went out and was
drinking and partying the next night so
i was like i don't know if we should
like give him money
the people who funds me are just weird
well if you flex to like if people
he flexes his louis vuitton not this guy
with the head injury the guy that got he
always sucks in his like
bug it's like at that point you can't
really ask for money like me and do a
setting with gofundme for my
birkin yeah i don't know
i i think america has a disgusting
horrifying problem where people have to
make gofundmes
instead of it's like
going a little bit deeper though the
problem is not kylie jenner
necessarily it's that our government our
our society values
the existence of billionaires and people
like well jeff bezos for example you
know and elon musk are worth like almost
200 billion
okay like kylie jenner is like a
broke-ass [ __ ] peasant piece of [ __ ]
because it's not even worth to be in the
presence of people so rich
damn the fact that we are you know
we look up to and respect and cherish
these people
and don't have the means for
for ordinary people to pay their medical
bills is just uh one of the greatest
crimes against humanity
because they don't have insurance they
can't pay them is that why
sometimes you have insurance and you
can't afford it too but but you know
what i mean like
but i don't know if they had insurance
or not uh what i heard they didn't and
that's why they didn't want to go to the
hospital
yeah but sometimes even with insurance
you can get stuck with a
super expensive bill because you have
like a high deductible where you have to
pay like 10 000 something
but like yeah they're in in the great in
the richest country on earth when you
have people like jeff bezos worth 200
billion dollars almost
people should not be going bankrupt
paying for just for life-saving surgery
it's just
it's disgusting what's the solution like
they pay like jeff bezos space
well the solution is complicated but in
most western developed countries like in
europe and canada and england
they have social medicine which means
that the taxes are usually higher
and the cost of treatment is a lot lower
because the government negotiates on
things like pharmaceuticals
pharmaceutical companies are some of the
most profitable businesses in america
they sell the same medicine to us at
about 10 times the price they sell it in
mexico and canada
because there's no regulations on how
much they can charge so that's in
combination with these
[ __ ] i mean we talked about
david dobry's [ __ ]
these people are these people are evil
evil they're literally lining their
pockets
with life-saving medicine and our
government's so corrupt for not
regulating it i'm going on a soapbox
here a little bit
that's one part the other part is that
um they do pay for your medication if
you're hiv positive there's programs
that'll pay for like your that's
probably uh
that's probably a third part that's
probably
not from the government yeah i mean
there's lots of great organizations like
that of really good caring people who
are trying to fill the gaps that are
[ __ ] pathetic excuse for
uh health care systems here can't do
yeah
i don't know yeah i mean she should have
paid for it but also that
guy shouldn't have to be making a
gofundme to pay to save his own life i
mean
[ __ ] pathetic he shouldn't have to
but he had to do so
yeah yeah yeah i agree i agree
i think so too um speaking of awful
people
james charles did you see he collabed
with charlie emilio again i'm like why
are you clubbing with miners bro like
let's stay away from the miners you know
james charles is more deserving to be
cancelled than maybe
yeah than anyone and he's still so
arrogant leaving comments on people like
someone's like oh i'm looking at trash
because they posted a tick tock with
charlie and like all these and it's
james dancing with them and he's like oh
the camera must be facing you you must
have himself it's like
why is he still so cocky like layla be
humble
i'm uh i'm pulling it up right now
oh okay oh but this one i'll show you
the one i was talking about yeah let me
go to this hi sisters
hi sister
so much here it is bruh people i mean
like
i james charles is as deserving to be
canceled as dilbert
and he's got i mean i can't blame these
young girls noah beck is that know
back oh probably oh yeah he's with that
girl
he got brushed you see that video of him
talking to paparazzi where uh
oh so i'll find this video of him the
paparazzi goes up to dixie and noah or
whatever at
going out on a date and like that was
right when james charles was trending
for this whole
sex thing with a 16 year old and he goes
do you have any comment about this
and he goes i love james charles nothing
bad to say about james charles this is
an actual like
admitted to a crimes with the miners and
you're still like i like
like that's why i don't f with like
dixie noah and charlie any of them
because like why are they hanging out
with this person this is like a [ __ ]
like it's a criminal like
and uh no uh back on james charles let
me try to find this
oh this one i haven't seen this one it's
crazy man thank you man long time a lot
of people men are wondering what
what the whole thing um
oh my god dixie what's going on with the
fashion tell me all about the fashion
you like the look it definitely is
something new can you talk about it or
are you under wraps
but i don't know if this is it but now i
mentioned something new
this is very very new how do you feel
about noah's new photo shoot
this man is like was those your words
it's crazy wow it's like a it's like a
horse collab
like if you want to collab with noah
here i think it's here oh god and notice
how the windows are down so it's not
like they're trying to hide or anything
there's another liza and david i feel
let's just like kind of
wow
a lot of questions about your new photo
shoot yeah
how do you feel um i just feel like
is this is there something you want to
tell us no man modeling's an art i mean
i'm just having fun
people shut up is that what he said yeah
the modeling's
i shouldn't deride the whole modern
modeling industry but it's just funny to
hear
him say that after like doing two photo
shoots modeling smart
i just feel like is this is there
something you want to tell us
no man modeling's an art i mean i'm just
having fun with it like people can think
what they want but at the end of the day
it's like you said
i talked dixie what are you doing
it's a car all right i can't find it i
love that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] car hold on i gotta go god
do you guys are
mad is that true lorraine no he's like
yo cut this far down
but is that because dixie can you get it
or what wait i gotta see the card game
were you trying to like oh the paparazzi
yeah i'm sorry
were you trying to like sub say
something that you like
had something guys go home i literally
don't have
any idea who i just want to like seem so
much more mature
thank you
so these i think it's in this clip i
think i heard it's not going well
but you kind of changed your vibe a
little bit you have like more of like an
emo
type vibe yeah have you like what does
this guy ask you about
a little bit more emo too you know a
little bit more
emo
you don't want to be happy so as soon as
you ask them about james they start
backing up
what's your reaction to the video that
you did with james charles where y'all
were singing it was like a little bit
off-key
look at this i'm sorry it's so crazy
because do you remember that one who was
it
there was like bryce hall or something
like pissed because um
the paparazzi was like filming him it's
like if you go to saddle ranch they go
there just to be
paparazzi so it's like don't go out to
salary and there's literally any other
restaurant and go we should go there and
see if they care about them no
i want to see if they ask if they even
notice us oh
that just sounds so awful but what if we
would
do something funny for the paparazzi
where like uh
i that's literally my biggest fear is
going to
seeing all these people at saddle ranch
hey is james trying to look sexy because
he looks like
you can make fun of james's looks
because he's a
p word right he's uh
but his hair and everything he looks
like a
he looks like a cartoon character or
some [ __ ] like
oh oh he's so [ __ ] cocky oh my god i
can't
and then the little 16 year old girl
next to all means like where are your
parents this pre like you're promoting
this guy to all your minor fans
it's so gross it's so disturbing to me
and dixie's smiling there and noah like
you are all
supporting this person like it's so
awful he he i know i talk about this a
lot but
james is an actual dangerous predator
and anyone that that
associates with him is going to have to
reckon with the fact that
they put their own fans uh in danger of
being preyed upon
this is what happens people just like oh
whatever it's cool like he's famous
we'll do this but it's like
later on you have to like deal with
repercussions of this dude he sent a
picture
allegedly it seems like based on what i
read
he sent a picture of his dick to a 16
year old
that's so disgusting that's unsolicited
nudes again
allegedly i'm i'm reading between the
lines of the article but he definitely
admitted to sex
engaging in a sexual conversation with a
16 year old and then blaming the 16 year
old by saying he lied about his age it's
like
uh like bruh you sh dude
bruh he's so cringy ugh
james oh my god i hate him he's the
worst who's worse him or
was it jeff bezos who did you say was
awful oh
you said someone was awful you're like
these people are awful was it the
government i don't know i totally zoned
out
i don't know if jay i don't know i i i
can't answer that question
so nobody else you'd like to cancel just
james
right now james is the worst for sure in
terms of like oh cancel
we can't cancel the government i don't
think we can't get no
no as far as i'm aware that's well they
try i mean sometimes they try to cancel
the government that's called like
we could have like a revolutionary war
are you ready to take up arms against
the government
oh my god and your joker outfit
i could do like a hamilton cosplay for
it
i would love that freedom i'm not ready
no i'm not ready
for for a revolution yeah are you ready
for revolution are you revolutionary
i could do or would you rather i could
do with or without you know
did you ever ask abe what he thought of
jeff's uh threats or not threats but
like his
proposition on the end of the episode
yesterday did they be saying
oh yeah he i was so confused because
jeff
i didn't even know what if jeff was like
trying to be like
was he trying to be a little like
light-hearted after was he trying to be
lighthearted or was he trying to be like
confrontational
i think lighthearted i think cuz like
youtubers versus tick tocker so he's
like oh i heard you're a tick tocker now
but also he said he's a fan of the show
and watches every episode but he doesn't
know who dan
is versus a b well to be fair dan
doesn't have a camera on our show he has
a camera on
i'm sorry but if you watch the show you
know who dan isn't you know what i have
known when i first yeah
i yeah yeah
i got caught in it anyway yeah he wanted
to fight a b
a b is down he said he'd fight him what
yeah he said he'd fight for you he did
he said he'd fight for you dan
since he seemed to be challenging us
both uh maybe it should be like
one yeah and like maybe and i versus
when he was coming for dan i was like
whoa
like do they have this deep conversation
before like what was it
just just swing for his eye his bad eye
oh
no but hey if that's what it comes to
well he yeah
anyways would you be in a bo what do you
think of that the
youtubers boxing tech talkers you're not
about it i'm not fighting anyone what do
i find
i mean do you have any opinion on it at
all like the whole
situation yeah it sounds like who cares
about the people fighting
it is weird how like wait is it austin
like broom or whatever
yeah the ace family versus bryce hall
it's not the whole ace family it's just
awesome the holy
family that now that i would watch
it's so cringe too because he's also
like his thirties i don't
care about either it will be a horrible
flight fight
it will not be entertaining and i don't
really care about either them so i'm not
that interested but it's a whole lineup
it's a whole lineup of youtubers
inviting a whole lineup of tick-tockers
and they're just like the headliners
yeah i didn't i don't know who the other
people are here let's pull up the
headline
hold on youtuber verse tick-tock
when is it happening by the way i saw he
offered ace family dudes
offered um bryce five million bucks i
was like holy [ __ ]
let's go how does they spend so much
money because they're such big houses i
know i don't get it
well we get it we did a whole um oh you
didn't do it
they scammed their fans yeah we did a
whole content court and they had like
this huge
so-called charity event for basketball
where they raised millions of dollars
and they only donated fifty thousand
dollars
how'd you find that out because it's all
i mean it's all it's all like public but
just nobody like really
has like found in all right we did this
huge charity basketball event he had
like
all these celebrities and [ __ ] and they
sold out the staples super expensive
tickets
and he's like i'm proud to announce that
we're getting fifty thousand dollars so
he's okay
proudly yeah he presented this check and
there was no i mean
there was no explanation for where all
the other money oh and he flexes so hard
too it's like these people who flex
their rolexes and rolls races and stuff
it's like okay also
he's such a goon it's crazy that people
like him
he is such a goon yeah he's so look at
him
he's like 50. it's like look at him well
this is kind of a great matchup because
they're both oh he looks like rocky
there kind of
doesn't even the brain damage part
[Music]
that's crazy about it the east east
celebs are the worst
i never did a content cop on david
honestly we
okay well we thought of we didn't we
think about it
i don't think so i guess we never
thought none of us had any idea just how
scummy
yeah yeah he's just not we never none of
us pay attention to him
i know even when i came on the podcast
like it's like few months after my
breakup and all that stuff happened like
there was no questions about damon jason
but everyone else's podcast i went on
and was like
that was the question like impulsive
they're like oh david jason like you
literally didn't ask anything you're
more focused on the trans
you just never really cared oh people
were asking it yeah i didn't even know
you were
even involved in that [ __ ] group like
that to me
was something i learned like after we've
basically started the show together
i didn't even know that that was such a
big thing in your life oh interesting
about you guys i guess that's why i
never watched h3 before because you guys
talk about the most random things like
your titles like what are these even
about
you guys talk about the most random
things well some of our recent ones were
real good like uh
how could you not click this let's see
no there was no
here how could you not click these
titles the titles are
um uh president trump calls in
i mean they're doing good i would have
called them yeah i was like oh no one's
gonna click on that and then they get
all these views so whatever um
that one's the worst well i guess you
were doing it for nft but the vape
nation thing i'm like i don't know
vape nation never heard of it you've
never heard vape nation
no and the thumbnail was weird it was
like you being
you know it's my favorite most famous
video i don't even know what that is you
want to watch it i mean we should it's
short
okay i guess this is my this is like
people know me for this video is this
really
it has 30 million views okay
no this is this video is a big deal
right dan
yeah i mean it's your most it's your
most popular video were you around
this is your most viewed video yeah i
have 160 million on my most viewed video
you do which video
um it's just a q a with one of my
ex-boyfriends 160
million why mm-hmm i have no idea what
i don't know wait wait wait wait that's
[ __ ] weird
i don't know yeah was it have like a sex
in the uh
in the title because back in youtube
yeah yeah back back back like back back
back in the day you could put like epic
blow job video and then
they didn't like censor it at all but it
is sex i think i think it's like how we
have sex or something
okay but even still 160 million how much
money did you make from that video do
you remember it's only like three
thousand dollars i looked the other day
it's only like a three thousand
uh which channel is it on the main
treasure dial for mj
bro you have a hundred and i don't think
any creator can claim to have that many
views on a single video
as far as i'm aware 172. oh it's gone up
our sex life yeah yeah i can see why
but then you got another one 45 oh these
were holy [ __ ] that's my arrow
sean [ __ ] fat girls who think they're
hot say which by the way sean is like
now dating jeffree star and like nobody
gives a [ __ ] like somebody sent me the
picture and i'm like nobody cares but i
love that they thought they were doing
something like wow watch us like break
the internet
like nobody cares is this really graphic
no it's just a few nights
already everywhere let's watch yours i
can't wait to see this it's already
seen cringe looking at the thumbnail
just fyi okay
this is okay watch it okay let me give
you a little context this is like
stop i'm out i'm out stop i just watched
your whole [ __ ]
music video with goats and sheep and
[ __ ] you can at least do me the honor
this was like back like five years ago
apparently around the same time you were
making my epic sex life videos
uh when vaping started was becoming
really popular uh-huh
so i did this whole character about vape
nation oh you did character work
yeah back in the day really yeah i was
big into character you were like the
miranda sings era you're like
shane was doing characters miranda sings
you
yes i love it i love that whole movement
i love that that's your boy ethan from
h3 h3
crank it crank it i hate watching other
people's videos with that it's so cringy
just watch it you have to if you want to
understand who i am as a person
you have to watch vape yikes stop
okay ready hey what up peeps it's your
boy ethan from h3h3
the sun finally came out it's a
beautiful nice warm day here in new york
city
and i wanted to show you all at home
what i'm about
a little peep into the world of ek from
h3
vape nation
having heard
[Music]
today i'm on a mission to rip the
fattest
vape so i'm headed down to my favorite
smoke shop in new york city
to vape up this is who's filming
oh no this medieval in the city that's
what it used to be like
all the time welcome to vape
city home of the fattest cloud rippers
in the world
i'm here to kick it out one of the best
let's check it out i would laugh at you
that's the idea
oh it is okay well hey what's going on
man i heard you all have vapes here
yeah we do cool dude
is this real yeah it's all real sick
so we building the perfect vape for the
perfect rip yeah
big niche but what flavor do you like
something natural like mountain dew
flavor or like
i don't know cheetos or something we
have this one did they let you film
organic churros yeah organic churro
flavor
i don't even know what a vape is what
are you buying that sounds good like a
cigarette
yeah it's like you have like uh you have
like
this syrup that has nicotine in it so
instead of smoking cigarettes
you hit the vape and how did this go
wire okay we can keep watching how did
this go because it's [ __ ] epic and
hilarious and funny
so someone share it like well i was
already
like a relatively big youtuber and how
many views did this get like the first
24 hours you remember
a lot so it's like six million yeah like
five maybe wow
this is weird this video is epic
landmark video
your entire h3 channel was like this to
me i'm like i don't get it this is so
weird but you don't understand meme so i
guess it's
are you just one big meme is that what
you're saying well
it's yeah okay meme king natural
churros flavor all right now we here at
the vape nature all about going green
and staying natural okay
so when i'm when i think about smoking
churros i'm thinking
you know what i mean go green
is this improvised yeah oh wow okay
i'm kind of impressed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not so hard take all of them out don't
keep them aside
you don't hold inside maybe you don't
i'm like developing
[Music]
how much you smoked so like this one
again it lasts you maybe four days if
you smoke
like all day really yeah probably lasts
me a couple hours
no good
okay
[Music]
it's just like i'm on my way back to my
hood now to try out my
oh this was my face but first i wanted
to stop by the local news and say
what up so there's this place in the
upper west side where
we live where they shot the news live
through this glass and he started seeing
he started yeah he started to notice me
he looks he's looking at you and i was
like no way so i turn around i start
interacting with him no and he's like
what
oh no you look so special
he's like i was like
no wait this is happening i was like no
way he starts recording me
[Music]
and i do this little narc edit
i felt like they were calling the police
[Music]
experience
so when this happened there was like a
whole group of people surrounded around
because they saw
it it was quite a spectacle were you
like loving it oh yeah that was like the
craziest i hate filming in public i hate
this kind of thing it's so embarrassing
to me oh it's so embarrassing
but like i knew that but you loved it
yeah i loved it no it's
crazy this moment i was like oh my god
this was like the best thing ever
we ran home with the footage and backed
it up because i was like
i was like i don't want to lose this
yeah you're really bad
what you really thought it's just like
gold you don't lose it yeah this moment
for sure
and after this by the way they never
they put
um the curtains down on the windows
every time i walked by they never shot
in front ever again okay that's kind of
iconic yeah people say i need to be more
supportive of you the way you are
supportive of my stuff so i'm gonna
try and get behind this i mean well if
you're not if you genuinely aren't
supportive then i did you
like really hate this video i don't hate
it
but like i feel like you have such a
cool factor about you now that people
are going to watch us the new viewers
that
you know are we'll see you in this and
like oh this is what
come on this is good really you think
this video's gonna make people lose
respect for me
i think they're gonna lose the coolness
for you like right now you're very brad
pitt this is jamie kennedy brad pitt
like the swag right you have the swag of
brad pitt but this is hey this is me
take me for what i am i'm no [ __ ]
brad pitt i'm i'm tom green
i'm jamie exactly exactly
yeah but we're almost done just bear
through you love top green but didn't
you no
not really you didn't love that no i
didn't i feel like you're the type of
people who find bum song funny
listen i just told you i didn't like it
i don't know if i believe that
i didn't damon kennedy didn't think he
was wrapping up
it nope i should have mentioned it
because i might get sued from him but
mom's the word on bob sage we talk about
later we'll talk about later yeah
let's go yeah that's a good topic okay
okay but i want to finish watching this
i'm supporting you again i am 4 20 every
day
you said everybody's going to lose
respect for me after they watch not
respect
lose the coolness in their eyes now i
see you as more of a nerd
look this is who i am uh okay oh you're
cool
but now you're kind of like ooh every
day look i'm having a great interaction
with the police about smoking
foreshadowing vape nation on the news
represent the nation y'all
4 20 every day every day every day
here's cancer is it legal smoking
[Music]
no that's good trust vape niche
appreciate it
my day is never complete until i've done
is this your full-time job at the time
to spread the good word
about the vape niche this is good
peace god bless
what's up guys go green
oh my god
[Music]
i'm about chasing the fattest clouds and
ripping
the fattest vapes welcome to the vape
nation
what is the vaporization it's just
something i made up
what are you selling though nothing it's
a gag i'm not selling anything
we said i'm selling the vape nation on
your h3
[Music]
are you impressed by my vape trick i'm
impressed by that whatever that was
what is that it's a vape trick that's
what i'm doing did evo shoot that
no no it's like a vape competition
i want a vape do you have one
um i don't think so wait it's almost
thank you i just asked and you said cool
no that's so weird
[Music]
so you hated it my best friend i think
maybe just like if it would have been
cut a little shorter like a little
edited quicker
a lot of people say it's a hallmark in
video editing the video editing was good
especially for that time
i think it was i think it was good okay
just be honest though i feel like you're
just trying to be supportive i don't
know how i feel about it to be honest i
think i
not to bring this out but i do think it
reminds me of like jack's films like i
think that's why
oh it all comes back to jackson i think
that's like guys are friends that's very
jax films like thinks it's funny like
sketchy kind of thing yeah like when he
was dressed up as hamilton and
i was like okay right right you would
have been great in that group tobuscus
right i see what you're saying you're
saying it reminds you too much of jack's
films and so therefore
you can't like it i just don't get it
it's like a meme like you said it's like
a meme
i don't know what vape is i don't know
what vape nation is i think it's um
you know out of ten give it a score oh
okay
um i'd say truthfully
i'd say six out of ten because the other
was good the bibliography was good
i respect the character thank you i
respect going on public
and like very much you know i could not
do it yeah
you want to talk about the sag i feel
like you would be you were pretty good
there but i feel like man on the street
stuff now you're like not as comfortable
with like you're not how do you know
what a man on the street like when we
got into like goat yogurt we're not as
quick like you're pretty quick there if
you improvise all that
not that you're not quick you know what
i mean i don't know i hate being on the
street chef in general like conan stuff
maybe cringe like the masquerading bear
like the dog ever all that makes me i
feel like i'm pretty good man on the
street but like you need to edit it you
can't just have like one
like you know what i mean we were just
getting a little bit of a shot
i like oh
wow i got an email from his lawyer can i
say that i guess they didn't say i
couldn't do it
wasn't a gag order no you get those from
moses only
pretty sorry
yeah gag order i don't gig i have pretty
good um
i think i have a loose throat you have a
loose throat it's that spray i told you
about adam and eve
i can't believe you actually spray
before you if you want to go down
like a deep throat does she ever use
that spray on you
[Laughter]
oh my god i'd be like can you imagine
if i went to eli like hey baby tonight
i've got to spray to numb your throat
she'd be like
are you [ __ ] kidding me with this
[ __ ] i think she would literally kill me
if i brought that up i think the girl
has to initiate that
yeah you don't want to bring that up
yeah can you imagine
eli i've got this spray makes your
throat numb so i can
so i can do push-ups on your face oh i
love that
that's kind of everything she'd be like
i am not talking to you
you are dead to me i love it actually
you know what it feels good
it doesn't your throat doesn't hurt the
next day but yeah i got a um
i got an email from you told me you
advised me to delete it it's so weird
how sometimes you become like my dad
like there's so many times where you're
like you should probably delete it i'm
like
that was like the one time no there was
another time you were very dead oh
why did you make this talk about dixie
and noah because i'm trying to
protect you don't you understand
sometimes charles a predator
no but you no but you weren't talking
about james shows you attacking their
relationship and i was like that's just
there's no point it's like they're
promoting james all attackers
you support p word then i don't care how
i
attack okay let me show the tick talking
question okay
because you didn't take my advice you
said i should probably delete it but i
is this i see is this okay should we
know about this because then we'll get
the cease and desist maybe well it's
already up on your ticket it wasn't a
cease and desist it was just a letter
i'll believe it maybe but then this will
be up forever if i delete it
yeah they can't i mean it's already up
on your take me to prison for this
nobody could sue you for what though
because i'm commenting on it
or i don't actually i don't think he has
any grounds to sue you because
what you're alleging isn't something
very specific
so i don't think he could sue you i'm
not alone i'm saying it's gross the joke
he made about
let's watch okay but this will be up
forever is what i'm saying so then the
lawyers
probably give you a letter to say take
this down on what you just edited well
no because
i think the context of the conversation
is important because i disagree i don't
think you should put this video up
also is litigation different than
lawyers
they said this is so and so from bob
saget's litigation
it means they're not gonna sue you don't
they do a cease and desist
no they don't have to do anything they
can sue you anytime they want i mean
i'll take it i have lawyers on a
retainer i guess um
i don't like the joke he made it's
disgusting i don't think that's like a
crime
no i don't i say it to the judge i'm
telling you i don't think he has a case
of defamation against you because
it's you're not specifically saying oh
he's this but i do
think that well let's let's go ahead and
watch the tick tock okay but this will
be in front of me forever so i don't
want you to get sued now but
i'm not worried about it okay i can
always snip it if i need to but i don't
i don't think it's like that
okay here we go freaking thrilled
that people are getting called out we
started with weinstein
um should have started with woody allen
who got away with
so much disgusting crap so
i'm gonna keep calling it out and i'm so
glad bob saget is now on the table
because
story so pause i do have
it's not my story to tell but i do have
like a personal friend that was like a
close friend of mine that had an
internet with bob saget that wasn't a
good incident so i do have some
sort of personal i guess like connection
to this like a lot of times people get
called out and like
something i don't call it everybody but
this one i was like wow okay good like
people are like noticing this you know
what i mean because this girl had a
thing
but she got silenced real quick not
through money or anything but just
scared like most people do right you get
a ladder you're like oh [ __ ] you know
dude bob saget is super [ __ ] rich
like he's like crazy right he's worth
like 200 wow
from full house i think because that
show was like such a big deal and he was
on america's funniest like in the 90s he
was a big deal
he is super [ __ ] rich really oh 50
million that's not as rich as i thought
he's not kylie jenner level no he's not
paid for your brain surgery rich
oh he's not i thought he was worth like
200 million well [ __ ] yeah
i mean that's great just don't get me
wrong 50 million he's collabing with
jamie kennedy he's on that wrench
so so anyway you're comparing him
so would you i wasn't marrying him i
said i like seeing people
he was our word okay but woody allen
was the key word in r word right let's
watch this again being pulled out and
i'm so
freaking thrilled that people are
getting called out
started with weinstein um should have
started with woody allen who got away
with
so much disgusting crap so
i'm gonna keep calling it out and i'm so
glad bob saget is now on the table
because
you're putting him in the company of
weinstein and allen
you see what i'm saying but that's not
what i was insinuating if that's how you
take it that's literally and i'll say it
now that is not what i was insinuating
but the joke he made was so gross okay
also it was trending on tick tock and
twitter so everyone's like comment box
you're not the only one yeah so that
again it's like the dixie eating the
snail thing everyone's like trisha talk
about the trust and at this moment i was
doing a string of q and a's this was the
day i came over to your house to have
dinner
i do find it it is really interesting
that like bob saget's legal team
saw this like so quick too i got it
within like a day they must have been
sending it to a lot of people on tick
tock
did a lot of other people remove their
videos they said they did
huh that letter was like yeah i wouldn't
want to i wouldn't want to deal with the
sag
but i'm not i i can give an opinion like
if you know i agree it's disgusting
let's watch the whole thing okay he's a
public figure
the story is about bob for saget
as a three-year-old kid they gave me a
doll to talk to for
rehearsal that you know and i just threw
it on the bed and i just started to
pretend
you know by the way you know bob sage is
like a shock comic like
every his whole career is surrounded by
sanctions but i do
think there's like a line that you don't
cross i think like joking about and i
even with shane i think like i like when
i really evaluated like all the stuff he
did like as jokes
it's like crossing the line you don't
have to say this was a three-year-old
actress that was supposed to be and i'm
pretending to you know
this isn't evidence that he committed
anything i'm not saying it's an evidence
i think there's no there's certain lines
you shouldn't cross about
kids children you shouldn't joke about
having sex with three-year-olds okay
so or otherwise it's disgusting he also
married someone 30 years his junior
which can just tell a lot about a person
the power play the manipulation all of
that
bob sagan is discussing and also
deserves to be canceled i know he's
irrelevant now
to really call out [ __ ] i know it's hard
to speak up but if you can't yeah you
didn't slam your other people and that
was also my call to this you definitely
didn't slander him and this girl that
had an issue with him like a serious one
and through laughing like well i won't
say where through a comedy club
um like she uh she's she was just too
scared she got silenced and i was like
so that's why
i look here's the thing i'm never gonna
like if people aren't comfortable coming
out their story just like those girls in
the david video
like i'm never gonna be like do it
because i was silent for so long but i
always like encourage people to but
because people have money like you said
you're like bob's like it's really rich
don't go against him it's like can i get
that because now i have money and i can
fight it but a lot of people don't
that's not the money
but on the same note about people who
are like well if james charles did this
why didn't they press charges or why
didn't david dover get suited like a lot
of people one don't have the money
two are too scared because people more
rich are gonna win because they have the
money to fight it
it's like it's such a scary you can't
just like suit like you should be able
to but you can't it's not that easy a
lot of people who don't have money can't
just do lawsuits against people
if they don't have the money like so i
hate that excuse it's like if
like jeff he goes well this is a legal
case it's like well a lot of people just
can't do it but bringing awareness to it
is you know just as
but again you're you're the problem i
had with this video which you can
disagree with me and say but i think it
comes off as you comparing bob sagat
who there who's made a joke against
people who are actual
you know uh criminals like terrible have
done terrible things
and so i think just in this day and age
you have to recur you have to be really
careful about who
you say that of because it
has so much weight how about instead of
bob lawyer's lawyer or bob said his
lawyer is sending me a note how about
they
have him issue a two-minute apology for
this joke because it's not
like in 2025 bob saget's whole career is
jokes like this he can't apologize for
this one
he's gonna have to apologize okay there
are some things that you just don't joke
about
dude you don't understand every [ __ ]
thing he says is something this
offensive
and then you should be canceled because
it's like perpetuating like this
it's a whole other world i just
apologize for this one joke you don't
understand what's happening
so those are out there and this is what
his career is and i have every right to
comment on it
and say it's disgusting like i agree but
i don't think you should insinuate that
he's just
i wasn't insinuating that's what you
took from me and i i'll say right now
i'm telling
you what i mean was not insinuating i
hear you
my intent was i this harvey weinstein
thing happened i'm watching the woody
island documentary right now which is
gross which jerry seinfeld
for you defending woody allen you're
also disgusting anyone diane keaton
defending woody allen like anyone
defending still woody allen is so gross
the fact that jerry he didn't defend him
he said
he he said like oh i will never someone
said to jerry seinfeld
i'll never watch a woody allen movie
again he's like oh you can't you can't
separate the
artist from the art i can no problem and
i agree it's like dude
it's like i think this is a situation
where you a little too flippant about
this dude who basically r-worded his own
dog but jerry seinfeld also dated a 17
year old and didn't think a problem was
that so i guess that's again once again
showing the kind of person he is
as a huge jerry seinfeld fan i think
that
take your finger off the cancel button a
little bit i know i'm getting a little
can't just
like yeah i'm gonna get canceled again
leave the button on the table
look but just slip away a little bit
okay i love jerry seinfeld
i think that i was also disturbed by
he's like oh i could separate it's like
dude you could like i understand how you
want to separate the art from the artist
sometimes but like
read the room a little bit on this one
like i mean i personally am not watching
any woody allen movies after i watched
that
right documentary which was outlined
some of the most horrific
abuse i've ever heard in my life and
people just continuing to praise him i
mean it was stephen colbert who was
talking to him too you know
steve go fair is pretty liberal right no
yeah so it's like this is coming from
someone of your own like people all
right you're both on the same side of
like politics and stuff it's like why
wouldn't you be like yeah
but also the way he said it was like oh
yeah no problem i was like
no what what stephen cabaret said was he
goes i can't separate the art you know
from the art
he's like he goes really you can't like
just so like what
why would you just so seinfeld woody
allen colbert seinfeld should have been
canceled when he did that coffees and
car show
like just end it just oh here it is wait
this is from three years ago what the
heck
i know that's what i'm saying it's all
recent wait uh my first guest on the
show
this has nothing to do with the
documentary
these allegations that were in the
documentary have been around for years
yeah it's not new information wait
they're talking about bill cosby it says
no but he talks about he talks about
woody allen and this too because they
showed it in the woody allen documentary
minutes long oh they did yeah that's how
i thought is the man responsible for
some well i'm not gonna watch a whole
10-minute clip
oh they are [ __ ] you colbert [ __ ] you
okay problematic
being called so anyway
i'm not deleting it i could have an
opinion i agree i agree
i was just listen i i agree you didn't
defend him
i do think people should be canceled for
certain jokes like i definitely am on
that side of the thing like i think
if you're not gonna like if you're not
gonna apologize for it like you said
that's his shock factor shane dawson
used that same excuse like oh i was in
shock i was doing stuff for shotgun
and i get it too but at least just like
apologizing don't repeat the mistakes
like don't do it again keep doing i want
to do the stuff i said in
2014 now like it's 20 21 like
stop look he's bob saget
who's that like who cares i had him on
the podcast
oh really long time ago i mean it wasn't
a big deal i never saw that one because
i see a lot of your i want to go to see
who's the most famous person on your
podcast and i never saw bob take it on
there
his sh the episode didn't get that many
views
however people didn't care um um
he was fine right then yeah he was nice
it was fun was jan
was he shocking in person was he like a
shocked comic in person
it wasn't that he he didn't say anything
that outrageous or anything now
it was a good time though he was he was
affable he's funny how long ago was it
oh it was a lot like three years ago it
was a while ago so were you like
popping off on your podcast like what
the first year the second year like when
was like h3 like
whoa the podcast because you had jack
black he had like a lot of big people on
i've always been popping off i'm a huge
deal
ever and since that vape nation video
came out five years ago before
and after well that vape nation didn't
do as well on your h3 today that it did
back then it only has like 650 000 or
something like that
the podcast that you did that i'm
selling vape nation it didn't get the
same amount of views
as you would think from a 30 million
viral video would get
like it didn't get a million views is
what i'm saying so like it's not as it's
old but you put it up in recently you
said i'm selling vape nation
yeah so what but i know but you said it
was like your most big thing right yeah
i've been talking about vape nation like
a billion times like it's not
new news i've like talked about vape
nation a trillion times
okay so what i'm saying is is like when
was your era that you were popping like
on h3 like when those were going
around when i made that video which was
when
i don't know 25 years 2015 2016. 18 or
2019
2015 or 16. bob's saying it was on
around the same time so it was all no
bob said
years after so your podcast comes out
after vape nation
i stopped making i stopped making h3
videos
and i started doing the podcast that was
like because i didn't like doing those
videos anymore
i was over it were you evolving with
youtube or you just didn't like doing it
anymore i think
i was just over i just felt like it was
creatively becoming too difficult and to
it just wasn't natural and
every time i would make a video it was
just really painful and difficult
and so we pivoted to the podcast and um
and uh we were at first doing both at
the same time but then eventually i just
did full-time podcasts because i felt
that it was
more uh of the type of content i wanted
to be making it just felt more natural
and that's it that's what we wanted to
be doing
shout out to philip defranco for talking
about
david dobrik yeah that's crazy
well it's kind of a good job i mean i'm
saying that sincerely i'm not trying to
be
no yeah oh are we trying to no i'm not
trying to be that i'm saying sincerely
like i'm glad people at keemstar too
i know we don't like to talk about
keemstar but he did talk about it in
a pretty fair light well there's only
there's really no way to defend david
you know what i mean
at this point it just felt yeah it just
felt like everyone was so silent and all
of a sudden everyone's like
verbally like phil defranco was enraged
in that one he's like this is insane and
i was just like
well finally but in a good way it's like
you know it says finally when people
realize that you're just so relieved
because you're just like finally like
people are like seeing this you know
it's like
because it's just dangerous i mean the
whole thing i mean obviously we don't
know what happened with jeff but like it
still continues to be dangerous and it
needs to like
um what are you up to this week
passover oh that's this friday friday
are you coming to our house on friday
not friday because you're yeah
are you coming over on sunday okay a lot
of trisha lately
i know like a little too much
two episodes back to back a couple of
passovers it's like ew
i'm also getting i don't know how my
face is gonna look the reason i was
originally not gonna calm
just full transparency is like i'm
getting this facial treatment tomorrow
that's like
my skin is going to start shedding like
a snake oh i would love to see that
well i might take a week i don't even
know so i might have to have like a veil
on the next front of me like i don't
know she said
do you have anything planned for the
next two weeks i'm like well i mean wait
what is the procedure you're doing
um it's supposed to shed your so all my
skin is supposed to shut off and it's
all the bare skin underneath is going to
come through but
you can't peel it so it starts shedding
like a snake around
and so what do they do to your face i
don't know i'm kind of scared some kind
of acid probably
not acid but maybe like lasering or
something like a laser and like a
peel or something as some sort of scrub
i probably do a tick tock on it because
it's like you can't wear makeup for like
you know a week it's a serious procedure
it's not like serious but it's like your
whole skin is going to shut itself i
gotta see that
i mean i'll do like a tick tock you know
showing that every day but yeah i'm kind
of nervous hopefully it'll be okay for
next week so i don't know
but i'm getting that done and um
yeah that's pretty much it how about you
what you're up to this week i
do the same [ __ ] and always do
which is teddy fresh podcasts
teddy trying to see if there's anything
else i was gonna say super excited that
um
we did this fertility thing so we're
gonna be finding out if he was pregnant
in like a week and it's not full ivf
right
no it's like they didn't take the egg
out of her body they did everything but
like because in ivf they take the egg
out
and the sperm and then they they ins
they like they do it in the lab right
yeah
and so basically they did everything
short of that so they just took my semen
and like put it up in her but we did all
the crazy shots and the hormones to like
plump her up and make her [ __ ] like
super
fertile oh my god and she's still so
skinny she's so lucky
usually she's not pregnant oh yeah she
said she felt bloated actually
so we'll find out in a week if she's
pregnant she's crazy you guys announced
it right away last time right
yeah we did they say there's like all
this superstition that you're supposed
to wait but me and eli don't care
because we like being
well first of all i'm not a
superstitious person i don't think that
talking about it's gonna like kill our
baby you know what i mean
i think it's more than you have to tell
people right right you're right but i
think
we were very honest and upright about
the whole process so we thought like
well if something bad does happen then
we're going to talk about that too
yeah a lot yeah i mean but we got really
lucky that you know the first time with
theodore was like just such a positive
experience from beginning to end
and so we got really lucky with that oh
my god what if it's like not as perfect
as theater or what if it's like a little
terror
the child just sucks yeah yeah
i mean then i'm gonna have to put it
over
yeah i'll just give i'll put him back
inside ela no problem right you can
return the baby
oh my god that sounds like a lot yeah i
don't know about having kids anymore it
just seems like it's a lot
after having your nephew
yeah i don't think i'm going to well
then if you have a doubt
after spending a few days with the baby
then maybe you're onto something because
i don't know there's no you can't you
can't escape
the baby i thought i was pregnant two
days ago was it two days ago i threw up
in the morning i got so excited
did you miss your period um i think i'm
like right on it i think it's supposed
to happen today i think like right why
did you throw up then
i don't know i got really nauseous i
gave my hair makeup done actually that
friday we came over here i was like
i just like threw up and then you had
your period no i haven't had my period
yet so you might be maybe i'll find out
too what if we got pregnant
well what then why don't you think
you're pregnant because i just i've just
never
i've never gotten pregnant so i just
feel like i can't so but you still feel
like maybe you are pregnant i mean it's
always like hopeful
why haven't you taken a if you've missed
your period you should be able to buy
like a day i wait
you want to take a pregnancy test we
have some wait let me see if i am missed
if i think
if you've missed your period even by a
day you should be able to take no but i
like to wait a week because mine is
sometimes like day to day
let's get that pregnancy test boys let's
do it live that's it i'll do it live you
will
yeah whoa crazy but there's no way
because what if we both are get pregnant
at the same time that'd be amazing
i know it's insane that our kids will be
cousins yeah that's so first
oh i feel like it's already over here
anyways it's like might as well
it would be it would be really cool if
the cousins were friends like really
close
and they'd be just such different
children which is like so funny oh my
god yeah
i feel like the cool mom is like you're
gonna be aunt
auntie trisha yeah theodore already says
my name yesterday he's like
trisha is this just a long kong because
i told you i wouldn't let you
oh my god when you first said that when
we started dating you're like so annoyed
are you really still just doing like a
crazy long con to like
get i would prove me wrong no oh my god
i think i'm like getting married and
bought a house and all this stuff just
to be over here
finally made it into the house that's
what the vlog squad thinks of you
they literally are like dude they
actually would believe that
i know it's so that's what's so crazy so
i try not to look so nuts but
um yeah wait we should end up we should
also end it by saying that
we should also support stopped asian
hate again stop the asian hate i'm glad
you mentioned that
it's outrageous that people are out
there doing this this is
sick the atlanta did you see this yeah
but the fact is
people aren't reporting it as a hate
crime they don't think it's racially
uh motivated but it was six of the eight
women were asian and it was in massage
parlors
it's like how are these not being
reported in hate crimes like okay so a
lot of people like okay what can we do a
lot it's like report it as like hate
crimes if you see something that's like
racially
charged if it's online if it's anywhere
like we have to report it as a hate
crime because it really is it's race
race induced you know yeah and the the
punishment is a lot heavy
i i but the guy's a murderer so like
what's the punishment but like
all the other stuff if you were if it's
a hate crime the punishment is much
harsher so a lot of these people are
getting off lighter than they should
regardless i have such a hard time
understanding like on a pers
on a human level like what is wrong with
these people
that are going and hating on
is okay he throws up every day huh okay
sweetheart i think he's just coughing
okay
it's it's it's hard to it's just hard to
the
concept to conceptualize the fact
there's people out there hating
hate committing asian hate crimes
because of the covet it's like it's like
that's crazy but that was probably
incited by donald trump which is good
he got cancelled cancel button back oh
yeah it was definitely it was different
from donald trump i mean there's no
question about it
there's no question you know it's just
proof that like
rhetoric and and uh racism
has violent consequences you were a
victim of hate crime did you talk about
that or no a while ago
oh you mean the swaddling yeah you think
that was racist oh it was definitely
the guy was a white supremacist who was
definitely uh that's crazy
that's crazy to me because it's not like
dude existing online as any minority or
anything is like constant [ __ ]
uh barrage of hate and racism but jews
especially have it pretty bad lately i
think with the whole white now the rise
of
i feel like white nationalism has become
kind of
having a wave of popularity here with
the trump
administration and i'm definitely
feeling the anti-semitism
more than i have in the past
and then the woody allen documentary
why because he's jewish it doesn't like
shed the best light right now on
he was a jewish american hero i don't
think anybody's
putting those crimes on all the jews
and maybe it just passed through my head
briefly
i don't i don't think people are going
cruising the street looking for jews
because of what
what he allen did there's plenty of
other reasons to hate jews i don't i
don't hate them just for the record
jews what are y'all in a heat yeah i
hate i hate woody allen oh my god
that was so disturbing embarrassing
right
cringe canceled button i had someone
send me email with a they're like oh
you're calling out white nationalists
why don't you talk about your own people
and he sent me a picture of um epstein
oh he's jewish yeah i was like okay i
guess
i don't if we can get into that
different i still understand what
epstein did i don't even know who that
like what he did
bro epstein was a legend in this world
he said though now
yeah he killed himself or some you know
he died
in prison yeah he died
oh epstein is the king of the [ __ ] like
in the world of uh
you know r word and essay and p word
he's the lucky
man i don't know anything about him so
epstein was like um
made a bunch of money in investment
baking whatever
and he was basically friends with a lot
of rich
and powerful people and basically
trafficked and um
underage girls to where what are you
trafficking on the moon too
he had a private island so there's an
island full of underage girls that well
he would bring them there
and then do stuff to them underneath a
lot of famous under 18.
yeah and then he but also there's a
great documentary about it on netflix
he had a house in uh palm beach right
that's like the really rich place in
florida
yeah and also in manhattan that was
where the other stuff happened
but a lot of well in this documentary it
was all about his house in palm beach
his his uh his uh
cohort uh you've heard of jizz lane
maxwell
his name's jez lane yeah i know her
name's jizz
i love that she's french love that she's
british
i thought she was french well how did
she well how did she explain her that
her name is
because
and she dealt exclusively in his jizz
what'd she do so she would get young
girls
i forget how she would scout she would
like scope
oh yeah dude it was crazy so like they
they would get young girls right
to come have sex with jeffrey and then
they would pay them
to bring their friends to come have sex
with jeffrey
it was they had like this whole underage
girl ponzi scheme
and then he would groom the ones that he
thought were really impersonable
and he would take them on trips and make
them do sex acts on his rich friends
he had like this whole sex trade of
underage girls
that wasn't more popular
i never heard of it he went back he went
down big time recently
although he dude the whole story of
epstein is crazy because he got caught
doing this like in the 90s and the
district attorney
basically dropped the charges it's like
a whole [ __ ] thing you should look
into it it's crazy
and he and he got caught he went to jail
and then he committed suicide
where all the cameras were the guards
were mysteriously not there and the
cameras weren't turned into kill them
yeah but is that a bad thing well
someone was covering their tracks
because he has dirt on all of it like a
fellow inmate that's like you're
no it was it was like someone rich and
powerful who didn't want him to flip
his person he was personal friends with
two presidents bill clinton
and donald trump donald trump was been
to his island
a bunch of actors prince andrew as
andrew he was famously friends with him
there's allegations against him and
epstein was was a
was a was one of the greatest that ever
did it he's the michael jordan of uh
he just bleeped this sex trafficking
yeah he's the michael jordan he's like
kobe or jordan
who's three though who's the kobe
uh um there's probably some really great
ones out there that we don't even know
those are the kobe's right they're like
kobe
three-pointer yikes that's sad i don't
know where i was during that when did
this happen
it's huge news i don't know yikes that's
so scary
i don't know where you ever are we
didn't eat this episode
i'm so hungry me too i have an idea we
can do an eating contest do you remember
did you watch
a coal show eating contest yeah like
like in terms of volume or what yeah
oh i'll i'll bear you no i think i can
win so anna nicole
had a show and she had an eating contest
it was her howard k stern her attorney
kimmy and like whatever but it could be
your attorney do you ever have it's kind
of funny
no but i think it's just funny you never
thought of a cool show you should look
up in a cold eating contest
they order they have to have the pizza
well you don't like pasta it's like
pizza i'll leave anything for
you can you bring it up can you show the
eating contest you can't puke but she
puked and she lost so you can't puke on
it oh it's that serious it's so serious
i've always wanted to do this it was in
studio city but they shot the place down
and a nicole eating contest or do you
get flagged for this i don't know i
don't know any of these roles
what network was the show it was on e a
while ago but
she really went off the hand uh yeah he
killed her
i think four and here it is
we got no more and more they're inside
of a restaurant there it is i was
explaining today
then you're like a small cheetah okay
she's kind of ahead of her time isn't
she
doesn't that look like me sometimes i
like i'm like oh my god is that me those
arms
so they eat the pizza then they go with
the pasta
and you can't throw up okay you can pass
forward if you want a little bit
okay no they come out with the pasta you
have to have like
i get it they eat what do i need okay so
when are we doing that and she and then
she gets pissed because she threw up and
she said she won and then she's anyway
that's a good show watching you want to
do eating contest yeah
when next week next week what are we
gonna eat pizza
pizza yes what do you like i guess you
should eat what you like hamburger
french fries i see meat's too hard to
like ingest that's why you have to eat
like pizzas and pastas
pizza then
you want to hear something f'ed up
actually regarding a pizza eating
contest that david and jason had me do
that's still up on jason's channel
they had me go to head to head with an
eight-year-old boy
that was in that family to see who'd eat
the most pizza and that little boy threw
up and they like kept it in the vlog
like he basically like
they they were like encouraging him
yeah it'd definitely be the boys but
obviously but like the little boy threw
up and they like kept all of that in the
vlog and they kept like him throwing up
and i was like this is a child like i'm
embarrassed that someone's saying guilty
by association like i
have so much god i just don't get it off
when i was like that they fed this poor
little boy until he puked
they said they kept saying like you go
go go and the guy's like i'm sick i'm
sick this little boy he's like i'm sick
i'm sick and i'm like
i'm eating so i'm like i really am like
not paying attention to it until i saw
the vlog
oh that's it and it's still up and i was
like this little boy like and all they
did was make fun of how fat he was he
was like
his name is vardanan and he was in the
world of a yeah and then when he grew up
a little bit they stopped
using him in the vlogs but yeah it was
it's anyways everyone with that but
these guys are so twisted they would
give people like
animals that gave gabby hannah like a
sugar glider that's illegal and then she
like didn't know what to do with it
she's gonna take care of it my dog was
because of david and jason they just
surprised me with it for a vlog and made
me keep it even though i never asked for
a dog i never took care of her dog i
never owned a dog in my life yeah that's
messed up
so i had this puppy that had all these
worms and i've never taken care of a dog
thankfully my mom and sister kept the
dog cuz like we would they got him in
like a little
puppy meal on the side of a road and
with no paperwork or whatever and he had
all these worms and all these sicknesses
and i was like but they did it all the
time they just give animals away i don't
like
they're so he's such animal abuse by
putting animals on top of people
screaming they put like a bear on me and
i was like screaming and then that
frightens little bears so like the
little bear was like probably triggered
and i didn't know all this at the time
because you're like blindfolded and
there's a little bear and alligators and
snakes it's crazy
anyways there's so much more to be
looked into but i'm down to do an eating
contest are we doing a theme well we
were gonna do the oddly satisfying next
week oh yeah let's do that i like that
better are we gonna smash cakes
yeah we've got all that planned we've
got a little thing so let's do it the
week after
because i definitely want to have an
eating contest because i'm pretty sure
that i will eat you under the table but
a pizza is nothing like you could eat a
pizza we should have something else to
keep eating
okay fine whatever you want is that
gluttonous does that make sense
it's disgusting i'm not going to eat
till i puke i'm not doing that no no
it's
you you have a set amount of food and
whoever eats it the fastest
there's no way you'll beat me i'm a
month you understand
like i have this power i am a such a
beast that i
i'm like the hulk i have to control it
because
you know it's like when hulk becomes i'm
always hungry like the hulk he's always
he goes
what's your secret i'm always angry i'm
always me too
i don't think you're going to win you
haven't seen me do a mukbang i don't
even chew my food people are like did
you even chew
i still wanted you remember when we ate
pizza in the podcast and i you're like
i like crush that pizza without even
thinking pizza to eat on the podcast
we ordered pizza once like back in the
day at the old studio and you're like oh
my god i can't believe how you're eating
that pizza
that's also cool let's not have cold
food you guys always have cold food here
you can keep it hot keep it
you choose the food you choose the time
i will destroy you
i will end your life metaphors
through eating when's our next theme are
we having a theme anytime soon or no
because if not we'll just go back to
normal i'm fine with that let's just do
a couple normal i need a break from the
whole
costumes i'm fine with that but you can
show up in costume i mean i'm not the
boss of you
hey shredder okay no i'm down i have a
couple sponsorships i gotta do normal so
okay i'll come normal um happy passover
summer pesa sumaia
pesam um
i love you moses stop the asian hate
um cancel epstein cancel trump he's
he's dead yeah he's dead yeah oh he's
dead
but honestly i don't feel bad like if he
did that to like little girls like do
you know
god for epstein no i don't feel bad for
you
well like the glee there was a huge
controversy with that actor from glee
that
that unaligned himself because he was
going to jail for being a p
he had cp on his computer and everyone
was like i guess they did like someone
didn't include him in a group photo of
people who died from glee because
there's like four people who died from
glee and they didn't include him in that
r.i.p
and then the one cast member was pissed
like why didn't you include him and he's
like well he's a p word and everyone's
like that's so disrespectful you should
include him still
i'm not familiar with that you don't
know yeah there's been like four people
who died from glee and one of them was a
he was proven p he was going to jail and
he killed he on alive himself well
epstein is one that there's no debate
over
people are yeah anything with children
that's what i'm saying like even jokes
like just don't make it like i get it
they were funny and edgy maybe at one
point i don't know why but like they're
not anymore so stop making them
apologize for them and
you know get more clever with your humor
get more clever yeah
i don't think louis c.k like [ __ ] all
over girls was funny either
no it was horrible wasn't that in his
comedy bit or something wasn't that the
shock
factor of him but i don't think people
knew that he actually was doing that
you know what i mean i thought he like
had jokes about it yeah he did but
people didn't know at the time
that he was actually doing it doing that
i knew
you did i knew before it ever came out
for real i'm not just saying that like i
knew i do know i know someone personally
i said too much i don't want to like go
and more into it because i feel like i'm
going to get superman everybody
i have more information on louis ck
we'll see you next week this was the
trisha episode yeah but i feel you
hijacked it a little bit
metaphorically what do you want me to do
just sit here and put like this and just
everything
thank you no you are you are the leader
of this most of the time
but i'm happy to produce we did it we
did the we did it so no eating contest
next week you guys let me know in the
contest i can prepare for it
in the week after night how do you
prepare are you gonna not eat or
something
no that's the
[Applause]
[Music]
you